Fortuna Düsseldorf gewinnt auch unter Neu-Coach Markus Anfang nicht, führt weiter mit Negativ-Trend und zwei Vereine können erst mal aufatmen. Wir sprechen mit Lisa Höfer und Tobias Rieger über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer und los geht's.
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Krossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Gili Landgraf.
Wagner, Martin Wagner. Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kort aus dem Bewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, willkommen zurück zur Ligatour, zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ihr könnt mich sonst im 11 Freunde am Abend Podcast hören oder generell im Rasenfunk-Universum. Schön, dass ihr wieder dabei seid als Zuhörende. Und wenn ich schon von wieder dabei sein spreche, dann darf ich als erstes Lisa Höfer begrüßen, die am Anfang der Saison schon mal da war. Hallo Lisa.
Hallo ihr Lieben, hallo in die Runde. Ich freue mich auch mal wieder mit am Start zu sein.
Ja, und du baust mir hier die perfekte Überleitung, denn auch mal wieder am Start ist. Nach quasi genau fast zwei Jahren hast du, glaube ich, das letzte Mal über deinen Verein hier gesprochen in der Ligatour. Hallo Tobi Rieger.
Hallo in die Runde. Und ja, kann gut sein, dass das schon zwei Jahre her ist. Ich glaube, das letzte Mal war ich dann tatsächlich bei Max und wir haben über die Euro 2024 gesprochen. Das war das allerletzte Mal.
Genau. Genau. Ich glaube, auch ein Projekt, das uns alle drei auf die eine oder andere Weise verbindet.
Oh ja.
Auch okay, dass sie vorbei ist. Sag ich jetzt noch mal schnell vertreten. Übrigens, die letzte Folge, bei der du dabei warst, hieß Tindern gegen Lieberknechtkummer. Die guten alten Folgen.
Oh, schwierig, ganz schwierig, würde ich sagen. Aber es ist ja besser geworden mit der Zeit.
Ja, und natürlich darf ich diese Folge nicht starten ohne ein herzliches Glückwunsch zum Derby-Sieg. Wir wollen hier ja…
Vielleicht sprechen wir im Laufe des Tages noch drüber. Mal gucken.
Genau. Und an der Stelle Liebe an Anna, die freut sich. Gut, wir wollen uns heute vier Teams im Speziellen widmen, die sich in unterschiedlichen Phasen von Kummer, Stichwort, befinden. Bei zwei Teams haben drei Punkte am Wochenende zumindest für Freude gesorgt und, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen die Negativspirale, in Anführungszeichen, bei einem der Vereine auf jeden Fall gestoppt. Aber bevor wir in den Deep Dive starten, wollen wir ganz allgemein einmal schauen, was ist los in der Liga. Und da würde ich doch direkt mal fragen, Lisa, was beschäftigt dich gerade in der 2. Liga und warum ist es der FCN?
Du hast die Antwort schon vorweg genommen. Natürlich ist es nach wie vor der Club. Ich bin noch so ein bisschen unentschlossen, ob ich mich über den Punkt und das 1 zu 1 gegen Kaiserslautern freue oder ob ich nach wie vor verzweifelt bin, was einfach die Stürmersituation angeht. Das wechselt sich so ein bisschen ab. Ich glaube, am Ende des Spiels war ich tatsächlich froh über den Punkt, weil ein klassisches Clubspiel wäre es natürlich gewesen, wenn man da 1-0 verliert. Ja, hatte einfach wieder alles, was den Club so auszeichnet von verschossenem Elfer und Wegrutschen, über das leere Tor nicht treffen, über ganz, ganz lange VHR-Checks, über dann doch noch Ausgleich 1-1 in der Nachspielzeit. Ja, ist nach wie vor das Thema bei mir. Ich habe das Gefühl, so schlecht ist die Truppe auch nicht und man müsste in der Tabelle deutlich besser stehen. Aber am Ende ist es dann halt wieder der Club und in jedem Spiel passiert was oder gibt es Situationen, dass man halt einfach nicht reinkommt. So Düsseldorf, glaube ich, der Sieg war total wichtig, hat Miru Klose ein Stück weit auch gerettet und hat gezeigt, dass es geht. Jetzt zumindest nicht verloren, aber die Stürmersituation, ich habe es schon gesagt, ja, das bereitet mir nach wie vor Kopfschmerzen. Und ich wünschte, ich wäre so optimistisch, wie der ein oder andere Kollege bei der Sportschau in der Redaktion, da habe ich heute ein paar Mal gehört, naja, die Punkte kommen schon und der Kader ist ja nicht schlecht und das sind alles gute, junge Spieler. Da wird auch das Ergebnis bald mal wieder stimmen. Das hoffe ich, aber so jetzt ein schnelles Erfolgserlebnis, vielleicht am Wochenende dann gegen Braunschweig, ja, würde mich schon froh machen aus Fansicht an der Stelle.
Genau, da gab es ja noch die Pokal Niederlage gegen Ilaatissen, deshalb ist man da ja nicht dabei, Entschuldigung, dass ich da den Finger nochmal so liegen muss.
Stimmt, wir spielen mit dem Club dann erst wieder am Wochenende.
Das ist nicht schlimm, das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Ich würde sagen, Tobi kennt das Problem.
Ich hätte mich schon gefreut, auch noch über eine Runde im Pokal und über den einen oder anderen Euro mehr, aber sehen wir es so, es ist zumindest Zeit zum Trainieren da.
Ich würde sagen, es kann ja auch gerade noch ein Vorteil sein, jetzt vor der nächsten Länderspielpause kommt und manchmal gehen dann ja doch die Körner so ein bisschen aus. Aber willst du dann generell sagen, wir hatten jetzt ein paar Trainerwechsel eben auch in der 2.Liga, würdest du weiterhin sagen, es war die richtige Entscheidung, nicht nur mit Miru Klose in die neue Saison auch zu gehen, sondern eben auch mit ihm weiterzumachen?
An sich muss ich sagen, sehe ich das Problem gar nicht so sehr bei Miru Klose. Und ich glaube, ich habe es in der letzten Folge auch schon gesagt. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, er ist so ein bisschen die ärmste Sau in der Situation, weil was da in jedem Spiel irgendwie zusammengekommen ist, wie oft er sich wahrscheinlich schon denkt, Mensch, ich hätte ihn gemacht oder würde ich noch auf dem Platz stehen, das denke ich zumindest als Fan sehr, sehr oft. Das ist so ein bisschen die Situation, wo ich auch sage, auch dieses Spiel gegen Kaiserslautern, das hätte ganz anders laufen können und wäre wahrscheinlich auch bei neun von zehn Mannschaften anders gelaufen. Dann triffst du halt den Elfer und Julian Justwann, rutscht da nicht so bescheuert weg. Da trifft ein Rafa Lubach das leere Tor. Dann hast du zur Halbzeit vielleicht auch schon eine ganz andere Situation. Deswegen sehe ich tatsächlich gar nicht so sehr die Situation als Schuld von Miro Klose, sondern wirklich eher so die Gesamtgemengelage, die wir glaube ich zur Saison besprochen hatten. So ganz, ganz viele neue Spieler, der Kader wieder auf links gedreht, viele Junge, dass das ein bisschen Anlaufzeit braucht. Ich glaube, das ist normal an der einen oder anderen Stelle. Aber gerade so die Stürmersituation im Moment, ich glaube nicht, dass das ein anderer Trainer ehrlicherweise jetzt besser hinbekommen könnte. Also wenn das nicht Miro Klose ist, der hoffentlich den Stürmer ein bisschen was beibringen kann, dann weiß ich nicht, wer. Deshalb, da sehe ich ehrlicherweise nicht die Situation, um die zu verbessern. Ich glaube, da müsste man jetzt noch mal tiefer gehen. Aber ich bin ehrlicherweise persönlich froh, dass Miro Klose noch da ist und hoffe, dass jetzt einfach die Ergebnisse, die er halt auch braucht, kommen.
Ja, der Vollständigkeit halber ist es gerade Platz 15 mit 9 Punkten. Ich glaube, wenn man es halt wirklich schafft, wenn man sich anguckt, es sind halt nur zwei Siege und drei Unentschieden dafür und dagegen stehen halt fünf Niederlagen. Ich glaube, wenn man es halt irgendwann mal schafft, eben auch aus diesen Unentschieden noch mal ein paar mehr Siege zu machen, ja, tolle Analyse des Problems, ich weiß. Dann wird es auch wieder besser. Aber ja, also es ist halt trotzdem, man befindet sich halt in einer Situation, wo es einfach nicht einfach ist. Also wenn man so ein bisschen guckt, wer es um einen herum, Düsseldorf führt, Dresden, Bochum, Magdeburg. Also ich glaube gerade, man hat so ein bisschen den Vorteil, dass man mit Bochum und Düsseldorf eben 2 Vereine mit drin hat, die auch ihren Erwartungen hinterherhängen. Ich glaube daher, ja, wird man glaube ich wirklich brauchen, bis, ich würde fast sogar sagen Zurück-Serie, bis man da tatsächlich noch mal drauf schauen kann und die aktuelle Situation bewerten kann. Tobi, hast du außer dem Spiel, auf das wir nachher auch, ich verspreche es, zu sprechen kommen.
Ganz kurz sprechen wir drüber, ganz kurz sprechen wir nachher drüber. Ich mache es mir in Anführungsstrichen einfach und gucke einfach nach oben auf die Tabelle, da wohl viele gerne hinwollen, wir natürlich auch. Schalke ist im Moment für mich, es ist ein Stück weit unfassbar, wie die sich in diese Saison gefunden haben. Sie haben das, was du gerade angesprochen haben, nämlich nicht. Sie spielen keinen Unentschieden, 8 Siege, 2 Niederlagen. Das ist natürlich immer so eine Sache, wenn du oben mit dabei sein willst. Diese Unentschieden kosten einfach Plätze. Wir haben es jetzt auch leidlich erfahren, mit zwei Unentschieden auswärts in Dresden und in Fürth, wo wir einfach vier Punkte liegen lassen haben. Schalke tut das im Moment nicht. Ich finde es schwer beeindruckend, wie der Gesamtsituation, wie der Gesamteindruck ist, den Schalke im Moment hinterlässt. Der Trainer allen voran. Wir erinnern uns da vor ein paar Wochen von richtig stabilen Aussagen. Die Fans möchte ich gar nicht weiter darüber sprechen. Auch das, logisch auswärts, immer eine souveräne Bank. Auch in Hannover waren sie letzte Woche... Egal. Machen wir schnell den Haken ran an die Geschichte. Aber man muss wirklich sagen, Schalke dieses Jahr, es ist ja nun auch wirklich die größte Mannschaft in der 2. Liga. Das ist ein Riesenverein. Also nicht, dass der Kader der teuerste ist, aber das ganze Drumherum ist einfach groß. Es ist eigentlich Bundesliganiveau. Und alle haben sich nach der letzten Saison schon gefragt, wo führt das dann am Ende des Tages hin? Und das ist vielleicht die Überleitung zu dem, was in der Zukunft noch kommt. Ich habe jetzt mal geguckt, die nächsten Spiele. Okay, Schalke darf Pokal spielen, im Gegensatz zu manch anderem. Aber danach geht es nach Karlsruhe, zu Hause gegen Elbersberg, die zumindest bis vor diesem Wochenende richtig gut drauf waren, und dann nach Münster und zu Hause gegen Paderborn. Das sind vier Spiele, von denen drei Mannschaften, drei Gegner aus dem oberen und stärkeren Bereich der 2. Liga sind. Dann sind wir am 14. Spiel, auch wenn Schalke dann immer noch unter den Top 3 steht, und vielleicht sogar ganz oben, dann sind die real dieses Jahr, glaube ich.
Ich kann schon mal versprechen, da wird Marc sicherlich in der nächsten Folge auch drüber reden, über die Vereine, die sich immer mehr an der Spitze etablieren. Ich habe das am Anfang der Saison gesagt, dass ich glaube, dass Miron Muslic endlich verstanden hat, dass niemand auf Schalke gerade schön Fußball sehen will. Die wollen halt wirklich den Fußballsehenden in der 2. Liga nicht nur zum Überleben, sondern wirklich zum Brillieren brauchst. Und das ist eben dieser körperliche Ansatz etc. Die gewinnen halt absolut dreckig zum Teil ihre Spieler, auch gegen Darmstadt zum Teil. Ehm, übrigens wäre witzig, einer gefühlt dieser 1000 Partien, die wir jetzt auch direkt nochmal im Pokal sehen. Ehm, ich persönlich finde das ja eher langweilig und es gibt mir nichts. Andere finden das super toll, weil Vergleichbarkeit. Und ja, natürlich, der Pokal hat seine eigenen Gesetze. Hier, ich packen Euro ins Phrasenschwein. Aber das ist schon, also, ich hab das letztens mal gesagt und das ist wirklich null respektlos gemeint, aber die machen so ein bisschen das, was Union in ihren ersten Saisons in der Bundesliga so gut gemacht hat, dieses selbe an Tor schießen und dann den Gegner wirklich so einschnüren und so frustriert durch diese Partie laufen lassen, dass sie es einfach schaffen. Und das ist schon sehr beeindruckend, ehrlich gesagt, zu dem Schalke, was wir eben in der letzten Saison hatten. Und da muss man schon mal sagen, Stand jetzt ist das eine positive Entwicklung für Schalke 04. Gut, ich würde ganz kurz noch sagen, der VfL Bochum, der hat unter anderem ja auch seinen Trainer gewechselt. Uwe Rösler ist da neu. Da gab es einen Sieg gegen die Hertha und einen Unentschieden gegen Kiel. Ich glaube, das ist ein ganz guter Auftakt. Zeigt, glaube ich, weiterhin noch durch das Probleme, die die Mannschaft hat. Aber ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist, war jetzt eben erst mal Ergebnisse einzufahren und nicht zu verlieren. Und das haben sie ganz gut geschafft. Wir haben noch zwei außersportliche Themen, die ich hier so ein bisschen mit reingebracht habe. Und zum einen geht es da um Preußen Münster und Mark Lorins. Darüber haben wir hier noch gar nicht gesprochen. Auch einfach, weil die Rechtslage, glaube ich, nicht so ganz einfach war, beziehungsweise man nicht so richtig wusste, wer erzählt denn jetzt inwieweit die Wahrheit. Und einmal nur so ein bisschen für den Rahmen. Im August hatte Preußen Münster seinen ehemaligen Kapitän Mark Lorins fristlos gekündigt. Seit September ermittelt eben die Staatsanwaltschaft Münster wegen Verdachtsaufveruntreuung von Spendengeldern. Lorins selbst hat ihm zugegeben, dass er zu spät war mit der Verrechnung der Gelder, klagt gegen die Kündigung und befindet sich nach eigenen Angaben aufgrund von gesundheitlichen Problemen in therapeutischer Behandlung. Jetzt gab es erst eine Einigung auf einen Vergleich vor dem Arbeitsgericht. Die Zustimmung hat Lorins aber eben letzte Woche zurückgezogen vor Ablauf der Frist. Und jetzt geht es vor dem Arbeitsgericht im nächsten Jahr weiter. Das einfach nur mal als Thema in der 2. Liga. Und dann gibt es ein Thema, was um einiges größer ist und sich schon sehr viel länger zieht. Und da geht es um das Fanprojekt Karlsruhe. Also speziell nochmal da auch zur Einordnung. Wir hatten das in der letzten Saison immer wieder als Thema. Es gibt bessere Leute, die das für euch einordnen können und resümieren können als ich. Aber trotzdem, am 12. November 2022 wurden bei einer Püroaktion im Spiel gegen St. Pauli elf Menschen teilweise schwer verletzt. Mehrere Mitglieder der Karlsruher Ultraszene wurden wegen Körperverletzung angeklagt und teilweise zu Haftstrafen verurteilt. Da laufen eben seit Sommer zahlreiche Berufungsverhandlungen von KSC-Fans vor dem Landgericht Karlsruhe da auch als Einordnung. Da sind manche Urteile niedriger gesprochen worden als eigentlich vor dem Amtsgericht. Drei Mitarbeitenden des Karlsruher Fanprojekts sollten dann als Zeugen aussagen. Die haben sich aber verweigert und wurden– oder geheweigert– und wurden letztes Jahr zu Geldstrafen zwischen 4.000 und 6.300 Euro wegen Strafverurteilung verurteilt. Das gelten damit als nicht vorbestraft. Ich glaube, es waren 90 Tagesätze. Am 16. Oktober wurde das Berufungsverfahren dann gegen Auflagen eingestellt und die Geldstrafen der drei wurden ungefähr halbiert, kann man sagen. Dabei ganz, ganz wichtig, weil das, glaube ich, den drei auch wichtig ist. Die betonen dabei übrigens immer wieder, dass diese Einigung eben kein Schuldeingeständnis ist. Also sie sagen weiterhin, wir haben hier nichts falsch gemacht. Und das liegt eben auch daran, dass es kein Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht für soziale Arbeit gibt. Also das betrifft natürlich nicht nur Fanprojektmitarbeitenden, sondern generell alle Menschen, die in der sozialen Arbeit arbeiten, was einfach ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Beruf ist, glaube ich. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns alle einig. Der Richter, der zum Beispiel auch nochmal auf die Signalwirkung aufmerksam gemacht hat, man müsste aufeinander zugehen. Und es gibt eben die Forderung für ein Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht für soziale Arbeit. Das wird vom Bündnis für ein Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht in der sozialen Arbeit. Das tut mir leid, das ist leider ein bisschen schwammiger Titel. Ich habe euch das in den Shownotes verlinkt. Fernszenen haben sich ja wirklich deutschlandweit immer wieder positioniert. Und es gibt ein Statement der Bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft, der Fanprojekte. Auch das habe ich euch verlinkt. So, sorry für den Monolog. Aber ich glaube, es war einfacher, das jetzt einmal kurz in Fakten runterzubrettern.
Zwei Sachen sind dabei vielleicht noch wichtig.
Ganz kurz. Ja, Tobi, gerne.
Sorry, dass ich dich da unterbrochen habe. Also ich glaube, das, was wirklich entscheidend in der Geschichte ist, das ist jetzt letztinstanzlich, das heißt, da ist Schluss. Also es gibt jetzt nicht noch die Möglichkeit, dass das eine Stufe weitergeht. Und du hast es gesagt, das wurde eingestellt, das Verfahren gegen Zahlung einer Geldbusse. Man kennt das aus anderen Geschichten auch, wo es dann heißt, ich habe das bezahlt, das ist aber kein Schuldeingeständnis. Das macht die Sache natürlich immer so ein bisschen schwierig, aber ich glaube, insgesamt sind die drei sehr, sehr zufrieden damit, dass sie allen voran weiterhin nicht vorbestraft sind. Und dass es, auch wenn es jetzt eine Strafe gibt, die gezahlt werden muss, eigentlich mehr ein Hinweis in die Richtung ist, wir müssen das Problem lösen. Also nicht das Problem mit den Dreien, sondern das Problem grundsätzlich mit der sozialen Arbeit und dem nicht vorhandenen Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht. Ob das jetzt tatsächlich dann soweit kommt und die Politik sich dazu einlässt, da irgendwas zu ändern, weiß ich nicht. Das müssen vielleicht Politik-Experten entscheiden. Meine Vorstellungskraft ist da im Moment etwas gering, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Aber zumindest ist es erstmal, was diese Sache angeht, ein Blick in die richtige Richtung.
Ich weiß nicht, Lisa, hast du da auch irgendwie das so ein bisschen verfolgt?
Wir haben es tatsächlich auch von Sportshow-Seite immer so ein bisschen im Blick gehabt und haben tatsächlich auch vor ein paar Wochen mit unserem Host-Format auf TikTok auch darauf geguckt. Ihr habt das gerade ja auch schon erwähnt. Es haben sich ja eigentlich alle Fanszenen auch solidarisiert, was ich ehrlicherweise auch in der Situation total gut und wichtig finde, weil das hätte ehrlicherweise auch jedem anderen Verein oder jeder anderen eine Szene passieren können. Und ihr habt es gerade, finde ich, ganz gut schon zusammengefasst. So es steht halt so ein bisschen dazwischen. Ist das Vertrauensverhältnis an der Stelle wichtiger oder dass man vor Gericht aussagt? Und ich finde total richtig, dass sich die drei so positioniert haben. Und auch auf diesen Konflikt will ich es fast nennen mit dem Erzeugnisverbeigerungsrecht, dass es halt in der Situation nicht gibt, dass man aber halt eigentlich zwingend bräuchte, wenn man nicht die ganze Arbeit und auch das Vertrauensverhältnis, das man sich über so ein Fanprojekt und über auch soziale Arbeit eben aufbaut, halt nicht zerstören möchte. Also ich glaube, so diese Diskrepanz, die da jetzt so ein bisschen aufgezeigt wurde, ist total richtig und wichtig. Ich bin auch gespannt, ob da was aus der Politik oder auch weiterführend dabei rumkommt. Aber ich glaube, so in der Gesamtkonstellation war das jetzt schon fast die bestmögliche Situation, die man irgendwie am Ende haben kann. Das wäre jetzt so mein Eindruck gewesen. Und ja, bin froh, dass das so zu Ende gegangen ist an der Stelle. Und ja, bin gespannt, was dabei jetzt noch vielleicht weiterführend passiert. Stichwort Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht eben.
Ja, gab ja tatsächlich, glaube ich, auch schon die Anträge beziehungsweise die Nachfrage an die Politik durch so kleine Anfragen, nennt sich das ja. Da sah es jetzt erstmal nicht so aus, als könnte man das verändern. Aber ich glaube einfach generell wäre das einfach super wichtig, weil wir haben einfach explizit beim Fußball super junge Menschen, die da reinkommen und die durch Gruppen sozialisiert werden. Und da ist es erstens super wichtig, Fanprojekte zu haben, die da eben auch helfen können, die unterstützen können. Und ich kann euch nur empfehlen, sprecht mit euren lokalen Fanprojekten, vielleicht auch, wie ihr sie unterstützen könnt, was sie zu dem Thema sagen. Das ist einfach immer super hilfreich. Ich weiß einfach, was das Fanprojekt hier in Bielefeld leistet und das ist wirklich total wichtig und geht eben über, ja, einfach Basics am Spieltag weit hinaus. Gleiches gilt auch für Fanhilfen, also auch die machen einen absolut wichtigen Job. Auch jetzt gerade in der ganzen Debatte um, ich sag mal in Anführungszeichen, Stadion-Sicherheit. Das ist ja auch nochmal sein eigenes Thema, wird jetzt hier zu weit führen. Das ist glaube ich wirklich ein Thema für ein Tribüngespräch. Liebe Grüße an Max, ich schlage das hier immer vor. Ich glaube, er hat da schon eine leichte Abnachung gegen mich entwickelt, dass ich immer so neue Themen reinwerfe, die man bestimmt viel länger besprechen könnte. Aber das ist einfach so. Das ist sicherlich etwas, was man nicht unterschätzen darf. Gut, aber wir haben jetzt lang genug über alles andere geredet. Deshalb kommen wir zu unserem Krisenverein Nummer 1. Da muss man wirklich sagen, der hat sich den Namen verdient. Es geht um die Spielvereinigung. Man ist auf Platz 14 mit 10 Punkten, 16 zu 28 Toren. Damit hat man die schlechteste Defensive der Liga. Und das mit großem Abstand nach 10 Spieltagen. 3 Siege, ein Unentschieden, 6 Niederlagen. Formtabelle in der letzten 4 Spielen. Platz 18 mit 3 Niederlagen und einem Unentschieden. Gab jetzt am Wochenende ein 1 zu 4 gegen Karlsruhe, sowie ein 0 zu 6 gegen Elversberg. Der letzte Sieg, der war, gegen Aminia Bielefeld im September. Oder wie Michi Fischer liebe Grüße sagen würde, dieses Spiel kann er sich bis heute nicht erklären. Michi, ich auch nicht. Aber lass uns doch mal auf Fürth schauen. Ich weiß nicht, Lisa, vielleicht einfach aufgrund der Nähe, das Nürnberg. Das frage ich dich jetzt einfach mal.
Warum hat mich das nicht überrascht? Ja, ich muss sagen, tatsächlich habe ich natürlich auch verfolgt, was in der Nachbarschaft so los ist. Ein bisschen, muss ich gestehen, schmunzelt man ja dann als Clubfan, wenn man die Ergebnisse sieht. Und als ich jetzt gestern auch noch mal so ein bisschen in der Vorbereitung in die Statistik abgetaucht bin, war ich dann doch echt erschrocken. Also ich wusste, dass es ja schlecht aussieht. Und du hast viele Daten und Fakten gerade auch schon zusammen benannt. Aber dass wirklich 28 Gegentore im Schnitt, 2,8 Gegentore pro Spiel, das war ehrlicherweise ein Fakt. Den fand ich dann so noch mal zu hören und zu lesen schon auch erschreckend. Ja, man kann so ein bisschen was erklären und man kann so ein bisschen was– Michi, hast du ja schon gegrüßt– auch irgendwie ableiten da draus. Und ich schwanke als Club-Fan so ein bisschen zwischen, finde ich das irgendwie eher unterhaltsam, weil ich natürlich aus der Clubbrille da drauf gucke. Oder finde ich es schon auch irgendwie erschreckend. Und das ist so ein bisschen das, wo ich auch sage so wow, also ja, da ist ein Umbruch passiert oder da ist ein Umbruch im Gange und ja jetzt auch schon seit einem guten Jahr. Ich habe gerade auch noch mal so drüber nachgedacht, da war ja auch der Club der Auslöser und es war auch eine 0 zu 4 Klatsche gegen Nürnberg. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das nächste Derby so läuft. Kann ich mir gerade aus Clubsicht noch gar nicht vorstellen, dass der FC N da vier Buden macht, aber das war ja so ein bisschen der Anlass, da alles auf links zu drehen und da hat sich auch ganz, ganz viel, viel getan. Ich glaube, Tobi hat sich auch ein bisschen eingelesen und Michi hat uns ja da dankenswerterweise auch ein paar ganz, ganz gute Insights zukommen lassen. Vielleicht hat es der eine oder andere auf dem Schirm. Man hat da ja wirklich so komplett aufgeräumt, Trainer entlassen, Zorniger weg, Sportchef raus, wollte so den großen Neustart irgendwie ausrufen. Ja, wenn man jetzt so auf das erste Jahr seitdem guckt, erfolgreich war der bislang nicht. Also ich sag mal so, man hat es als Clubfan nicht leicht, aber ich glaube als Fürth-Fan geht es einem wahrscheinlich gerade noch ein bisschen schlechter.
Siebte, Zwölfte trefft ihr aufeinander.
Es ist noch ein bisschen, jaja. Mal schauen, wie es bis dahin sich entwickelt. Aber ja, also ich sehe es gerade aus beiden Seiten nicht so. Es könnte noch mal so ein richtiger Krisengipfel werden, auch wenn ich mir das natürlich aus Club-Sicht nicht wünsche.
Ja gut, auf jeden Fall, es führt immer für Tore gut. Das kann man glaube ich ganz sagen. Aber einfach um, was du gesagt hast, Lisa noch mal zu unterstützen. Also man hatte ja, nachdem man sowohl Zorniga als auch eben Azusi entlassen hatte, hatte man ja Jan Sievert als Trainer geholt, der gewann aber nur 6 von 20 Spielen. Übrigens ein Punkteschnitt von 1,1. Thomas Kleiner ist seit Anfang Mai im Amt, also war er erst als Interimsthäner, eben für zwei Spiele hatte er dann einen Schnitt von 2,0. Und deshalb hat man ihm eben auch in die neue Saison geschickt. Er hat jetzt allerdings einen Punkteschnitt von 1,18. In dieser neuen Saison, das ist es jetzt nicht, könnte man vorsichtig sagen. Aber ich glaube, es wäre eben auch zu einfach zu sagen, ja, es liegt nur am Trainer. Also, weil ehrlich gesagt, muss man ja erstens sagen, okay, hat man als Fürth im Sommer keine Alternativen gesehen. Also, kommt ja auch immer dazu. Aber das Problem ist, glaube ich, und Tobi, du kannst gerne gleich auch was dazu sagen, das Hauptproblem ist, man weiß, glaube ich, immer noch nicht, welchen Fußball will Thomas Kleiner eigentlich spielen. Also, weil das ganze Spiel von einem gut aufgelegten Neu-Footcoy und Felix Klaus auszulegen, ist kein Spielplan. Also, vor allem nicht in der 2. Liga. Das wird auf Dauer nicht funktionieren.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen haben sie… Also, ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, führt hat sich viele Jahre mit Branimil Higota so ein bisschen, hatten sie immer so eine Leuchtturmfigur, das hat gut geklappt, der hat das dann geregelt, wenn es irgendwie problematisch war. Wir wollten den auch mal haben, das hat auch nicht funktioniert. Aber der war, glaube ich, glücklich in Fürth und der ist da gerne geblieben. Erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Baris Atik in Magdeburg. Beide kommen jetzt langsam in ein Alter, was nicht hoch ist, aber was zumindest für Fußballer nicht mehr so ist, dass sie zwingend auf dem Peak sind. Und ich glaube, Fürth hat es so ein bisschen verpasst, frischen Wind da reinzubringen. Und da sind wir dann vielleicht auch bei dem, was du gerade gesagt hast, liegt gar nicht nur am Trainer. Wenn ich mir das angucke, von den ersten Felspielern, die die meisten Spielminuten haben, sind 4, 29 oder älter. Und das heißt, die bauen natürlich auf die Erfahrung. Okay, kann man positiv auslegen. Aber wenn ich das dann kombiniere mit solchen Sachen, wie Fürth läuft am wenigsten, Fürth sprintet am wenigsten, Fürth macht am wenigsten intensive Läufe, kann ich mir das vielleicht schon zusammenreiben, dass da irgendwie auch ein Zusammenhang ist, dass die Mannschaft einfach nicht das ist, was man in der zweiten Liga eigentlich braucht. Laufstark, kampfstark und fit genug, um da mithalten zu können. Und ich finde, das sieht man dann einfach an den Gegentoren. Wenn man jetzt das Spiel gegen Karlsruhe am Wochenende sieht, dann kommt noch dazu, dass immer noch mal jemand einen individuellen Fehler einbaut. Einmal rückt einer nicht raus, dann rückt irgendwie keiner raus und dann wird der rückraumlich nach der Ecke vernünftig verteidigt. Dann hast du irgendeinen wilden Spielaufbau, wo du dann den Ball verlierst und dann kann Karlsruhe da relativ zügig 3-0 führen. Und das Ding ist eigentlich durch, bevor es durch war. Also es ist im Moment sich wenig Hoffnung befürchtet. Ich trau denen jetzt zu, dass die warum auch immer gegen Lautern unter der Woche im Pokal gewinnen und dann mit so einer leichten Selbstgefälligkeit sagen, ja, im Pokal sind wir noch dabei und den Rest kriegen wir schon hin. Es riecht einfach komplett nach einer ganz gefährlichen Saison. Ich will nicht sagen, dass wir absteigen, da gibt es noch ein, zwei, drei andere Kandidaten in der Liga, aber ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, als Fürth-Fan wäre mir reichlich unwohl im Moment, würde ich sagen.
Die Frage ist natürlich auch, kannst du dich darauf ausruhen, dass zwei, drei Teams schlechter sind? Dafür muss man einfach sagen, das Spiel führt zu lange in dieser Liga und hat eigentlich so ein Level, die sei es auch gerne.
Alles gut. Ich finde tatsächlich genau diese Frage, gibt es wirklich zwei, drei schlechtere Teams? Auch wenn ich mir jetzt die Kader angucke und statistisch hat Tobi gerade auch zwei, drei Sachen reingegeben. Also das ist genau das, wo ich mir denke so, boah da wird es kritisch. Also was machst du denn dann, wenn sich dein einziger Tor gachernt, Furtkoll hast du ja gerade schon erwähnt, wenn der sich vielleicht noch verletzt oder was kommt denn dann noch nach? Also auch mal so ein bisschen über die Saison noch gedacht, wäre das tatsächlich ein Team, wo ich jetzt so nach den ersten Wochen auch sagen würde, da weiß ich nicht, ob ich die Qualität im Kader sehe und da weiß ich auch nicht, also ich sehe auch keine positive Tendenz. Spielidee habe ich mir witzigerweise hier in meiner Vorbereitung auch mit drei Fragezeichen aufgeschrieben, weil ich auch so sage, so sehe ich da jetzt auch noch nicht. Also da erkenne ich ehrlicherweise jetzt auch keine positive Entwicklung oder keine positive Tendenz und das ging ja auch in der letzten Saison so zu Ende. Und da würde ich auch sagen, puh, ja, kann ich mir als Klubfan so mit einem kleinen Lächeln angucken, aber dann denke ich auch wieder, boah, nee, eigentlich will ich ja auch nicht, dass die absteigen. Ich will ja auch schon gerne ein Derby weiterhin haben. Und also würde ich mir ehrlicherweise auch Sorgen machen als Fürth-Fan, weil ich nicht überzeugt bin, dass es wirklich zwei, drei, vier Teams gibt, die auf die Saison gesehen schlechter sind.
Ich glaube, das Problem ist eben auch, es hat sich so ein Schneeballsystem entwickelt. Also es wird dann immer wieder von Kleine gesagt, man arbeitet an den Defensivproblemen und dann siehst du aber ja alleine zehn Gegentore in zwei Spielen. Und da hat man natürlich schon das Gefühl, also erstens siehst du dieser Mannschaft eine brutale Verunsicherung an. Also sobald die einen Gegentor kassiert, da läuft ja nichts mehr zusammen. Also da werden die individuellen Fehler auch immer mehr, was du natürlich nicht ausgestellt kriegst. Also solange du eben kein Spiel mehr zu Null hast, wird es glaube ich auch einfach super schwierig. Und gleichzeitig sage ich halt auch, man muss leider aussehen, es liegt zum Teil einfach an der Qualität in der Abwehr. Also du hast mit Philipp Zier als jemanden, den du geholt hast, als erfahrenen Spieler, der das alles so ein bisschen aufräumen soll und das so ein bisschen sichern soll. Das funktioniert halt überhaupt nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Und dann muss man sagen, man hat ja eigentlich auch Neuzugänge, vielversprechende Neuzugänge im Sommer geholt, aber die spielen halt einfach nicht. Um Tobis Punkt noch mal zu unterstreichen. Also es ist ja einfach wirklich so, dass da doch wieder die Alten stehen. Klar, Brandy Myogoda sagt das das erste Mal seit gefühlt 300 Jahren mal auf der Bank. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das ein interner Statement war, weil taktisch hat es null geholfen. Muss man glaube ich ganz klar so sagen. Also hatte 0,0 Impact auf das Spiel.
Ich glaube, das war kein taktisches Ding. Das war so ein Denkzettel, wie man sagt. Ich glaube, der Mutter war ja dann auch recht schnell. Also er hat ja den 3-1 Anschlusstreffer, glaube ich, gemacht und dann lief er auch so Richtung Bank. Und also das roch auf jeden Fall ein bisschen nach Problemen. Es wurde gerade gesagt, sie dürfen halt kein Gegentor kriegen, sonst ist der Ofen schon aus. Das perfekte Beispiel, dass das leider nicht immer stimmt, war das Spiel gegen Hannover. Da haben sie zweimal zurückgelegen und irgendwie immer noch ausgeglichen. Aber auch da, und dann kommen wir vielleicht nochmal zum Thema Spielidee, einmal war es ein Fehler von Matsuda von 96, der im Aufbau den Ball verloren hat. Da hatten sie Glück, dass ihm quasi das Ding hingelegt wird. Und einmal klärt Blank nicht richtig und dann konnte, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was, Abranghau, irgendwie so in die Richtung, in seinem ersten Spiel, genau, hatte er dann gleich sein Tor gemacht. Aber das war ein Spiel, also ich bin, glaube ich, lange nicht mehr so gefrustet, aus Nürnberg bzw. aus Fürth nach Hause gefahren. Wobei, das stimmt eigentlich auch nicht. Eigentlich waren wir immer gefrustet nach Hause. Egal. Das war eine lange Rückfahrt und wir waren echt schlecht genommen, weil 2 zu 2 in Fürth, das fühlte sich auf allen Ebenen und nicht nur bei dem Blick auf die Tabelle fühlte sich das einfach komplett falsch an. Das war nicht dolle von Fürth und deshalb waren wir wirklich sehr angefressen, dass wir da nur einen Punkt mitgenommen haben. Also, ja, es ist mit Recht das erste Team, wenn wir hier die Probleme aufzählen, dass wir mit denen anfangen, nicht nur, weil sie in der Tabelle ganz unten stehen von den vier Teams, die wir heute bearbeiten.
Ja, und ich glaube, dazu muss man noch sagen, es gibt eben auch da nochmal Dank an Michi eben auch einfach im Hintergrund in der, ich sag mal, personellen Ausstellung des Vereins die Problematik. Man hatte eben vorher zwei gleichberechtigte Geschäftsführer mit Azusi und Holger Schwiegwagner, der ist der Finanzchef. Der ist jetzt alleiniger Geschäftsführer. Stefan Fürstner ist ihm als Sportdirektor unterstellt. Es heißt halt vom Aufsichtsrat, es sind keine finanziellen Möglichkeiten da, einen Sportgeschäftsführer und einen Sportdirektor zu bezahlen. Das ist eben ein Punkt, auf welchem ich glaube, dass sie Azusi nicht mehr zahlen müssen, weil er bei Aachen jetzt ist. Das ist aber tatsächlich gerade ehrlich gesagt mehr Unwissenheit, also mehr Verdacht als wirklich Wissen an der Stelle. Und dann ist es halt so, du merkst halt ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen in den Aussagen der Verantwortlichen, dass sie glaube ich auch nicht mehr so richtig weiter wissen. Also Fürstner hat gesagt, Rückschläge gehören dazu, wir müssen lernen, damit umzugehen. Aber du hast halt immer das Gefühl, also wann sprechen wir denn jetzt von Rückschlägen und wann sprechen wir einfach von einem Level, woraus sie es einfach nicht mehr rausschaffen. Also ich glaube, Phrasenfunk hatte das im Forum gesagt. Es gibt nicht dieses berühmte Level, auf das sie immer wieder zurückfallen, sondern dieses Level wird immer niedriger und niedriger, je mehr man sich selber da quasi reinfrisst. Und es ist ja, also es fehlt ja wirklich, ich weiß, ich predige das glaube ich seit drei Jahren hier, aber die haben halt keine Konstanz. Also da wirklich, ich meine, Michi und ich scherzen über dieses 3er in Zimbielefeld, aber danach folgt ja nichts, wo du denkst, ja dann baut doch darauf auf. Also baut doch darauf auf, dass ihr eine Mannschaft, die euch chancentechnisch eigentlich überlegen war, einfach komplett die Segeln aus dem, nee, den Wind aus den Segeln genommen habt, so rum, Sprichwörter, weil ihr sie einfach mit den Toren überrumpelt habt und damit komplett totgestellt habt quasi. Aber das ist ja überhaupt kein Level, was sie mehr hinbekommen. Ja, sie hatten das 2-2 gegen Hannover, klar, da könnte man aber fast auch schon davon sprechen. Naja, sie hatten halt auch irgendwie nichts mehr zu verlieren irgendwann in diesem Spiel. Also da ist ein Verein hingekommen, der einfach auf so einem hohen Level auf der Saison, also tun sie ja immer noch, wir erklären nachher, warum Hannover 1996 in diesem Segment gelandet ist. Aber das ist ja, also, weiß ich nicht. Ich, wie gesagt, ich würde auch noch nicht mal sagen, übrigens als Fun-Fact, Stefan Leitel hatte auch nur einen Punkteschnitt von 1,24, seinen 121 Spielen. Ich war ein bisschen überrascht. Aber es wird, also, ja, naja. Ja. Irgendwie weiß ich auch selber nicht, wo ich gerade mit dem Punkt hinwollte. Aber das ist, das ist absurd schlecht, was Fürth da zum Teil macht. Tobi gerne.
Ich hab noch vielleicht zum Abschluss zu diesem Fürth-Teil ein fanpolitisches Thema. Du hast, als du so eingeleitet hast, hast du gesagt, die Spielvereinigung Fürth. Und ich weiß nicht, ob du das absichtlich gemacht hast, dass du das Kräuter weggelassen hast. Das ist ja gerade, okay, das ist gerade in Fürth ein großes Thema. Die Umbenennung bzw. die potenzielle Umbenennung, die sie nächstes Jahr auf der Jahreshauptversammlung im Winter 2026 beschließen können. Jetzt haben sie noch vier Tage Zeit, wenn du in den Verein eintreten willst und da dann abstimmen willst, hast du bis 31.10.2025 Zeit. Und als wir da waren vor, was war es jetzt, drei Wochen oder so, also man konnte vom Bahnhof bis zum Stadion und auch im Stadion nicht einen Schritt machen, wo nicht irgendwo ein Plakat hingen, dass man eintreten soll, dass man sein Mitgliederrechte dann wahrnehmen soll, abstimmen soll und natürlich in die Richtung, dass man das Kräuter aus Spielvereinigung Kräuter Fürth streicht und es dann zukünftig nur noch die Spielvereinigung Fürth ist. Fand ich ein ganz spannendes Thema, gerade als jemand, der sehr große Veränderungen durch Vereinsbeitritte in den letzten Jahren in seinem eigenen Verein hier hatte. Ist das etwas sicherlich im kleineren Niveau. Ich habe die Zahlen gelesen, wir reden da von 4000 Mitgliedern. Also man kann relativ zügig relativ viel bewirken, wenn man eine Dreiviertelmehrheit hat, die natürlich auch nicht so ganz einfach zusammenzubekommen ist. Aber ich bin gespannt, wie das ausgeht in Fürth, ob sie es, ich glaube 20 Jahre danach so ungefähr wieder hinkriegen oder vielleicht sind es auch schon 25, sich wieder zurück umzubenennen.
Ja, genau. Ich mache das tatsächlich immer mit Absicht, weil ich finde, wenn man weiß, dass es bei einem Verein wirklich so ein Thema ist, dann ist das irgendwie auch ein Zeichen von Respekt, sie als Spielvereinigung zu bezeichnen. Generell, du hast es gerade angesprochen, es gab eben, glaube ich, auch eine Tapete gegen Karlsruhe mit Werdemitglied.
Ich glaube, die gibt es jedes Spiel.
Bei Fürth. Ja, genau, das ist gerade wirklich ein großes Thema. Aber von der Fanszene an sich, also generell übrigens auch politisch gesehen eine sehr stabile Fanszene, wenn ich das noch sagen darf. Ich glaube, sie hatten auch Plakate gegen März, Stadtbildaussage, das wollen wir jetzt nicht diskutieren. Aber das ist auch immer wichtig. Falls ihr in Fürth wohnt, das hört, euch überlegt, wollt ihr Mitglied sein und ihr wollt eine Fanszene mit korrekten politischen werden, dann do it. Ich habe hier gesehen, wie schnell man, vor allem mit sportlichen Erfolg, kommt einfach ins Pokalfinale. Dann ist das gar kein Problem mit Mitgliedern. Zahlen wir euch. Damit müsste man halt natürlich anfangen im Pokal gegen den FCK, auswärts bei Paderborn und dann zu Hause gegen Preußen Münster. Ich sage mal so, wenn man sich gegen Paderborn ungefähr so anstellt wie gegen Hannover, sollte da was drin sein. Sonst sehe ich da auch eher nicht so positive Vorzeichen. An der Stelle natürlich nochmal als letztes Mal eine Empfehlung an den Führterflachpass mit Michael Fischer, der hier eben auch Teil des All-Star-Teams ist. Der kann euch das in sehr viel länger, sehr viel besser erklären, als wir das gerade gemacht haben. Und natürlich auch seine Artikel für die Nürnberger Nachrichten. Ich liebe diese Alliteration jedes Mal. Das macht mich einfach sehr glücklich. Dann würde ich aber sagen, wir kommen zu Krisenkind Nummer 2. Und das ist Fortuna Düsseldorf. Steht ein Platz über der Spielvereinigung. Auf Platz 13 hat die gleiche Punktzahl mit 10 Punkten, 9 zu 18 Toren. Also nach der schlechtesten Defensive kommen wir zur schlechtesten Offensive mit Magdeburg und Nürnberg zusammen. 3 Siege, 1 Unentschieden und 6 Niederlagen. Vom Tabelle sagt Platz 15, 3 Niederlagen und 1 Sieg. Ich habe hier übrigens, das habe ich bei Fürth gar nicht eben gesagt, es gibt so eine X-Point-Tabelle, wie sehr man der Bedeutung schätzen will. Das könnt ihr alle selber entscheiden. Da wäre Fortuna Düsseldorf auf Platz 15 mit 11 Punkten. Also, das ist natürlich ein bisschen verschoben. Führt wer eben übrigens auf Platz 18. Macht damit, was ihr wollt. Mann hat sich nach der Niederlage gegen den FCN von Daniel Thune getrennt. Der war ja dreieinhalb Jahre im Amt. Neuer Trainer ist ein alt bekannter Name, Markus Anfang. Gab als erstes eine 1 zu 2 Niederlage gegen Braunschweig und jetzt das 0 zu 1 in Berlin am Samstag. Tobi, ich würde mal mit dir anfangen. Fandest du den Trainerwechsel nachvollziehbar?
Ja, irgendwann muss man vielleicht. Also ich bin kein Fan von diesen Trainerwechseln, so ganz im Allgemeinen. Also zumindest nicht, wenn sie zu schnell kommen. Und ich finde, wenn ich jetzt die beiden Trainer miteinander vergleiche, dann hätte ich für meinen Verein eine ganz klare Präferenz, wer da der Trainer ist und hätte dementsprechend natürlich nicht gewechselt. Besonders nicht bei der Alternative. Aber ja, ich kann halt auch verstehen, dass man in Nürnberg irgendwo, Nürnberg, Entschuldigung, in Düsseldorf irgendwann ein bisschen unruhig wird, wenn man auf die Tabelle blickt und auf solche Faktoren, wie du gerade aufgezählt hast, geschossene Tore und ja auch die Tendenz im Moment. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das sich irgendjemand in Düsseldorf leicht gemacht hat, diese Entscheidung zu treffen. Aber ich glaube, es war am Ende nicht ganz verkehrt, dass sie gekommen ist. Also Daniel Tune hatte es nicht leicht, finde ich, wenn man auf die Transfers zu dieser Saison guckt. Es ist als Zweitligist schwer, wir wissen das alle, da brauchen wir nicht groß drüber zu reden. Wenn du wirklich Spieler hast, die die liefern und dann kommt irgendein Verein oder irgendeine Mannschaft aus der ersten Liga, sei es aus Deutschland, sei es aus Italien oder wo auch immer, da ist mehr Geld, die Spieler sind weg, du kannst die nicht halten. Also kannst du es vielleicht machen, dann grüße nach Berlin, aber es scheint ja auch nicht immer so gut zu funktionieren, wenn man dann alles auf ein, zwei Spieler an Geld und ja vielleicht auch Macht im Verein oder in einer Mannschaft setzt. Von daher hat es Düsseldorf schwer gehabt und Daniel Tune hat es natürlich auch schwer gehabt, wenn man jetzt guckt, die elf Spieler, die am meisten gespielt haben, davon sind acht Neuzugänge und dann ist es halt nicht selbstverständlich, dass das von Spieltage eins funktioniert. Von daher hätte ich vielleicht Daniel Tune, um deine Frage abschließend zu beantworten, noch die eine oder andere Chance mehr gegeben, aber ich kann es halt irgendwie dann doch nachvollziehen, wenn man am Ende sagt, nee, wir müssen an dieser Stelle den Cut machen und den hat Düsseldorf gemacht und jetzt ist es nicht so gut gelaufen, wie man sich das vorgestellt hat. Also zu Hause gegen Braunschweig zu verlieren, ist das eine. Dieses Ding, ich glaube, wir haben es alle am Samstag im Topspiel gesehen gegen Hertha. Junge, Junge, Junge. Also wenn es da 3-0 oder 4-0 in der Halbzeit steht für Düsseldorf, dann ist das Ding auch schon erledigt und alles ist gut, dass es dann am Ende in der schlechtmöglichsten Situation den Gegentreffer gibt. Hatten ja sogar noch die Chance, das 1-1 zu machen, aber grundsätzlich mit dem Abpfiff quasi das 1-0 kassiert, ist halt wirklich, wirklich bitter gelaufen in einem Spiel, was ja insbesondere, wenn man die erste Halbzeit anguckt, sicherlich auch in eine andere Richtung gehen kann. Aber ja, jetzt ist das, was Markus Anfang machen sollte. Gute Laune, frischen Wind reinbringen. Ich glaube, auf der Homepage– ich habe es mir hier sogar angeklickt– steht so was wie, wenn der Inhalt stimmt, wird sich auch das Resultat anpassen. Das hat Markus Anfang bei seiner Präsentation oder über sich da gesagt.
Das klingt ein bisschen nach Kalenderspruch.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht so ganz genau. Also aktiv, mutig und viel Beibesitz mit frühem Pressing. Und dann hat er diesen Satz, den ich eben zitiert habe, daraus gehauen. Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht. Es mag auch an mir liegen, dass ich Markus Anfang nicht alles so abnehme und nicht der größte Freund von ihm bin. Aber im Moment ist es noch nicht so, dass dieser Trainerwechsel sich voll und ganz ausgezahlt hat.
Ja, da würde ich per se erstmal mitgehen. Natürlich ist es immer einfacher zu sagen, wenn man die ersten zwei Spiele gesehen hat. Ja, das hat nichts gebracht, worauf man auf jeden Fall gucken kann, ist, dass es ja schon klare Unterschiede zu Tune gibt. Also manchmal erkennt man ja die Unterschiede da ja nicht direkt. Ich würde sagen, bei Fortuna hat man das relativ schnell gesehen, alleine was den Spieleaufbau betrifft. Ich weiß nicht, ob man da generell so Fehlerketten unterbinden wollte. Also man hat jetzt eben nicht mehr so einen Mittelfeldspieler, der in die Innenverteidigung rückte, also diesen klassischen Dreieraufbau, sondern man hat eben eher diesen, diesen anderen klassischen Aufbau, sag ich mal, über die Innenverteidigung und dann über die Außen. Kastenmayer wird auch nicht mehr so ganz viel eingebunden, beziehungsweise wenn hat er eben direkt eigentlich die langen Bälle. Und man muss ja wirklich sagen, es ist halt super schwierig, vor allem nach dem 0-1-Satz gegen die Hertha, du hast alle richtigen Punkte schon gesagt. Dazu kommen natürlich viele Verletzungen, beziehungsweise Ausfälle. Na, an erster Stelle natürlich Cedric Itten, der hat eine Beckenprellung, die er sich eben allerdings auch erst im Spiel gegen Braunschweig zugezogen hat. Also das ist jetzt nichts, was die letzten Wochen komplett erklären würde. Sotiris Alexandropoulos, der hat einen Muskelbündelriss, da ist nur eine drin, keine zwei. Weil Gelundal und Tim Rossmann, die fehlen schon seit September. Dann musste man auch nochmal zweimal verletzungsbedingt auswechseln mit Zimmermann und Kenneth Schmidt am Samstag. Also da kommt dann auch irgendwie alles zusammen. Aber Lisa, es ist ja trotzdem so, dass wir Fortuna Düsseldorf vor allem daran messen, weil man eben vor der Saison gemeinsam mit der Hertha eben das Ziel Aufstieg ausgerufen hat. Wie würdest du denn dann auch gerade auf Fortuna schauen?
Ja, also ich glaube, der Aufstiegszug, um da direkt mal aufzuspringen, den sehe ich eigentlich als abgefahren. Also ich glaube, auch Klaus Olofs hat das die Tage ein bisschen so eingeordnet, dass das Ziel war, ja, dass man da jetzt eher mal so ein bisschen nachschärfen muss. Und also ich glaube, dafür ist jetzt einfach schon zu viel Abstand. Ich glaube, du hast am Anfang gesagt, eine Rang 13, 10 Punkte. Also da sehe ich ehrlicherweise trotz der vielen Spiele, die wir noch zu spielen haben in der Liga, wenig bis keine Chance, wenn oben alles normal weiterläuft bei den aktuellen Top-Teams. Und ja, also ich glaube, ihr habt viele gute Punkte an der Stelle schon gemacht. Also ich glaube, auch Düsseldorf hat so ein bisschen dieses typische 2.Liga-Club-Problem. Du hast ein paar gute Spieler, die sind aber dann auch einfach wieder weg. Grüße nach Köln, wenn du dann so einen Johannesson einfach abgeben musst und verlierst. Und die Neuzugänge, ich finde, da sind auch gute Namen dabei oder da sind auch gute Spieler dabei, wo man auch, glaube ich, sich an der einen oder anderen Stelle ein bisschen mehr erhofft hat. Ich glaube, Rasmussen war jetzt gerade in deiner Aufzählung nicht dabei. Itten hast du auch genannt. Ich glaube, die sind zum Beispiel noch nicht so bei 100 Prozent oder da kann noch mehr kommen. Dass ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch sagen würde, Düsseldorf hat für mich mit dem Abstieg nichts zu tun. Also die sehe ich nicht da unten drin hängen bleiben. Aber dieses große Ziel oder die Ambitionen, die man hatte, plus die Situation, wie sie dann halt wirklich jetzt so sich über die ersten Spieltage entwickelt hat, das ist halt, glaube ich, klassisch falsch gelaufen an der Stelle. Und jetzt ist so ein bisschen mein Eindruck, man muss irgendwie Schadensbegrenzungen betreiben. Ich würde auch sagen, der Trainer wechselt das Tat weh. Auch wenn man, glaube ich, kein Düsseldorf-Fan ist, hat man irgendwie schon so gemerkt, boah, das fiel allen Beteiligten nicht leicht. Ich würde aber auch sagen, es war irgendwie eine richtige Konsequenz an der Stelle. Vielleicht hätte man auch noch ein Spiel oder zwei abwarten können oder müssten. Ich verstehe aber auch den Gedanken natürlich mit der Länderspielpause. Ich würde schon ein bisschen Credit in Richtung Markus Anfang, obwohl ich auch nicht sein persönlicher Fan bin, geben, dass man sieht, da hat sich ein bisschen was verbessert und die Spiele hätten auch anders laufen können. Also ich glaube gerade das Hertha-Spiel, 22 Torschüsse war, glaube ich, die Zahl, die ich mir hier rausgeschrieben hatte. 22 Torschüsse gegen Hertha, puh. Wenn du dann 1-0 verlierst, Last-Minute, ja, also da sage ich auch wieder, was willst du als Trainer machen oder was hättest du als Trainer groß anders machen können. Also würde man, glaube ich, auch noch mal ein bisschen anders drauf gucken, wenn dieses Spiel anders gelaufen wäre. Aber ja, Aufstiegszug sehe ich weg. Aber ich würde auch sagen, mit dem Abstieg, auch wenn sie jetzt gerade damit hinten drin stehen, werden die für mich nichts zu tun haben.
Stimm ich dir voll und ganz zu?
Ja, auf jeden Fall schon sehr harsch.
Ich wollte Lisa noch auf jeden Fall zustimmen in der Geschichte, was das mit dem Nichtabstieg angeht. Die sind nur drei Tore besser als Kräuter Fürth, aber ich glaube allen voran, da sind wir wieder bei diesem Thema, diese Substanz oder dieses Level, was man wieder erreichen muss. Bei Düsseldorf gilt das. Die können das wieder erreichen. In meinen Augen haben die dann nichts mit den Plätzen 13, 14, 15 und tiefer zu tun, sondern werden sich irgendwann wahrscheinlich in der oberen Tabellenhefte eintreffen. Ganz für ganz oben, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht noch ein bisschen lang die Saison, aber ich könnte mir auch gut vorstellen, dass das nichts wird. Auch wenn der Trainer, und jetzt haue ich noch mal einmal auf den Trainer reiten, schon nach seinem zweiten Spiel in der Pressekonferenz, nach dem Spiel so ein bisschen in den Selbstmitleid-Modus verfällt und sagt, es tut richtig weh, dass wir hier verloren haben und wir haben schon acht verletzte und kriegen noch zwei dazu jetzt. Also Markus Anfang ist schon wieder auf allen Bereichen at his best. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich mir das nach den Spielen noch angucken kann oder ob ich dann vielleicht lieber die Pressekonferenz skippe, wenn er dabei ist.
Gut, generell Respekt, dass du dir Pressekonferenzen von gegnerischen Vereinen anguckst, in der Masse anscheinend. Ganz ehrlich, tue ich nicht, einfach weil ich meistens Pressekonferenzen, wenn du eine gesehen hast, hast du das Gefühl, meistens alle gesehen. Habe ich immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl. Ja, aber ich glaube einfach, man muss Markus Anfang Zeit geben, man muss ihm sicherlich auch die Zeit nach der zweiten Länderspielpause, die er jetzt bekommt, die insgesamt dritte in dieser Halbserie geben. Den, ich sage mal in Anführungszeichen, Vorteil haben wir ja, dass wir eben diese drei Phasen haben, jetzt jeden Monat, im September, Oktober und November. Aber ich glaube eben auch, das aller, aller größte Problem, was Fortuna ganz, ganz schnell in den Griff bekommen muss, ist die Konteranfälligkeit. Also weil da muss man einfach sagen, das darf eigentlich nichts mit Verletzten zu tun haben. Das ist wirklich, eigentlich, das klingt immer so stumpf, aber das ist ja eigentlich Verteidigung one on one vor allem, wenn du gerade in einer schwierigen Phase stehst, dich halt einfach nicht in so einem Konter laufen zu lassen. Das ist natürlich genau dadurch, dieses Tor auch noch entsteht. Das hat natürlich auch viel mit guter Einselleistung zu tun, am Ende von Kartenmacher. Und ich möchte hier auch gar nicht die Diskussion aufmachen, wer wollte es am Ende mehr. Klar hatte man schon das Gefühl, dass Hertha hinten raus einfach doch vielleicht auch mehr Körner hatte. Was irgendwie auch verständlich ist, wenn du zweimal verletzungsbedingt wechseln musst, dann bringst du vielleicht auch nicht die Spieler, die du bringen wolltest, um frischen Wind reinzubringen. Aber mir fällt es auch irgendwie schwer, da jetzt so abschließend zu sagen, das hat funktioniert, das hat nicht funktioniert. In diesen beiden Spielen, ich glaube generell, das ist einfach für den Kopf unfassbar schwierig, jetzt da rauszukommen. Aber ich glaube gerade von dieser Leistung gegen Hertha, da kannst du schon aufbauen, auch wenn das halt dir erstmal nichts bringt. Ich glaube tatsächlich so komisch, wie das im ersten Moment klingen mag, aber man spielt jetzt Mittwoch im Pokal gegen Freiburg. Und ich glaube jetzt mal in ein Spiel zu gehen, wo du wirklich von Anfang an weißt, dass du der Underdog bist. Gar nicht mal wegen deiner Tabellenposition in der 2. Liga, sondern einfach weil es einen Klassenunterschied ist. Da bin ich schon sehr gespannt, was wir da von Fortuna sehen. Und da glaube ich schon, dass wir da vielleicht nochmal mehr, ja, Markus Anfang Fußball sehen werden, wie wir ihn ja zum Teil eben auch bei Lautern gesehen haben. Zum Beispiel meine Frage ist halt einfach eher generell bei der Personarie Markus Anfang. Er hat es halt am Ende immer nicht geschafft, diesen letzten Schritt Richtung Aufstieg zu gehen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob, also das ist wirklich, soll erstmal nichts gegen ihn sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob das an menschlichem liegt. Aber so bei Dynamo Dresden als auch bei Kaiserslautern hat es ja hinten raus dann nicht geklappt. Und da frage ich mich dann schon, was mit ihm langfristig das Ziel ist. Und da muss man ganz, ganz klar meiner Meinung nach Klaus Olofs dann ins Spiel bringen. Weil ich finde dann einfach, das ist eine Persona, der muss er sich messen lassen. Und da muss man dann natürlich fragen, gab es schon Anzeichen im Sommer, dass es mit Daniel Tunig funktioniert, etc., PP. Und ich glaube, das ist dann eben der Punkt, wo Olofs, das wurde hier auch bei Marc in den Sendungen öfter besprochen, Klaus Olofs ist nicht der Mensch, der irgendwie auf den Mund gefallen ist, sondern der ja auch relativ klar dann auch austeilt. Und da ist dann halt irgendwann so ein bisschen die Frage, wann ihm das auf die Füße fällt, meiner Meinung nach. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr zu der Persona hier sonst auch Anmerkungen habt.
Ich finde, du hast es gut abgeräumt. Also hast eigentlich alles nochmal reingerührt. Und ja, bin auch gespannt jetzt auf den Pokal. Also das kann ein klassisches Pokalspiel werden mit der Überraschung, aber da kann man auch Böse draufkriegen.
Genau, dann haben wir eben das Pokalspiel gegen Freiburg, dann zu Hause gegen Lautern und auswärts in Kiel. Und dann wollen wir auf den dritten Verein im Bunde kommen. Ich habe schon mal angekündigt, die Laune ist jetzt ein wenig besser, als sie vielleicht noch vor dem Spieltag gewesen wäre. Es geht um Arminia Bielefeld. Man steht auf Platz 9, man hat 13 Punkte, 19 zu 16 Tore. Gemeinsam mit dem FCK hat man die zweitbeste Offensiver hinter Elversberg. Vier Siege, ein Unentschieden und fünf Niederlagen stehen bisher zugrunde. In der Formtabelle ist Platz 14, also es gibt drei Niederlagen und ein Sieg. Das ist so ein bisschen der Grund, warum wir auch darüber sprechen wollen. Denn vor diesem Sieg gegen Elversberg, den das kann ich euch versichern, ungefähr vielleicht 0,2 Prozent der Bielefeld-Fans so vorhergesehen haben, gab es vier Niederlagen am Stück. Und zwar gegen Fürth, Hannover, Schalke und Paderborn. Und das Schlimmere waren daran eher auch noch die zwölf Gegentore, vor allem gegen Paderborn und Hannover waren das ja zum Teil Auftritte, die Fragezeichen mit sich geführt haben, möchte ich sagen. Und bevor ich hier jetzt einen langen Monolog über meinen Verein halte, was ja einfach niemand hören will, und ich glaube, das passt so, würde ich euch einfach tatsächlich mal fragen. Und Lisa, ich würde mit dir anfangen, was ist denn dein Eindruck von Bielefeld bisher?
Also, ich verstehe, dass man nach den vier Pleiten so Krisengefühle hatte. Und wir hatten ja schon festgelegt, dass wir über Bielefeld sprechen, bevor auch der Sieg gegen Elbersberg eingetütet war, der mich auch überrascht hat. Aber ich hätte ehrlicherweise, wenn ich an Bielefeld denke oder mir jetzt auch den Saisonverlauf so angucke, ehrlicherweise gesagt so, die Wahrheit liegt ein bisschen in der Mitte. Es ist auch wieder so ein Euro fürs Phrasenschwein. Aber so mein Eindruck war, der Saisonstart, der war schon sehr, sehr positiv. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, overperformed. Das ist irgendwie ein bisschen zu einfach vielleicht gemacht an der Stelle. Aber ich fand es schon überraschend, wie stark Bielefeld da auch als Aufsteiger, das vergisst man ja irgendwie auch an der einen oder anderen Stelle vielleicht immer mal wieder, da in die Liga gestartet ist. Ja, jetzt diese vier Pleiten in Folge habe ich so dann auch nicht kommen sehen und ich verstehe dann auch, warum man von Krise spricht. Aber für mich ist das so ein Club, wo ich sage, wird mit dem Abstieg nichts zu tun haben, wenn es so nach meiner Expertise geht. Ich habe aber ehrlicherweise auch Elbersberg als Absteiger getippt, deswegen hinterfrage ich mich da auch an der Stelle manchmal. Dass ich aber sagen würde, jetzt also am Anfang ein bisschen overperformed, dann so eine kleine Krise, jetzt glaube ich kommt so ein bisschen Ruhe hoffentlich rein. Also ich glaube, der Sieg, gerade weil er so unerwartet war, hilft da an vielen Stellen. Und für mich wäre tatsächlich Bielefeld so solides Mittelfeld, wenn ich auf den Saisonverlauf gucke. Und gerade so statistisch, wie gesagt, ich habe mich ja so ein bisschen versucht, vorzubereiten, auch mit Deep Dive an Zahlen und so, was eigentlich gar nicht meine Stärke ist. Da gibt es schon wirklich ganz, ganz viel, ehrlicherweise, was einem, glaube ich, Mut macht als Bielefeld-Fan. Also meiste Laufdistanz, meiste intensive Läufe, 19 Tore ist irgendwie der dritthöchste Wert in der Liga, zweitmeisten Sprints in der Liga. Also kämpfen und arbeiten und da auch wissen, in welcher Liga man spielt und welche Tugenden es irgendwie braucht. Das sehe ich komplett. Deswegen würde ich mir da um Bielefeld jetzt keine Sorgen machen und würde sagen, so pendelt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich langsam so ein bisschen ein. Ja, man dachte am Anfang vielleicht, da geht noch mehr. Das war aber, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen zu viel an der Stelle, vielleicht, was da alles geklappt hat und wie auch die Ergebnisse gefallen sind. Und ja, bin froh für alle Bielefeld-Fans. Ich kenne tatsächlich auch einige, also auch in Köln. Shout-out, gibt es echt viele Bielefeld-Fans so in meinem Umfeld, dass es jetzt für die wieder ein bisschen positiver ist, weil da gab es auch schon so das ein oder andere Negative in den letzten Wochen.
Gar nicht, was ihr meint. Tobi, du hast Bielefeld, ich gehe mal davon aus, auch über 90 Minuten gesehen. Vielleicht kurz deine 2-Cents zu dem Spiel, aber generell auch gebe die Frage an dich weiter, wie siehst du Bielefeld momentan?
Also das war ein Spiel, wo ich dann tatsächlich hinterher dachte, okay, richtig und wichtig, dass wir das gewonnen haben, wir lagen 1-0 zurück, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht und haben es dann gedreht. Das war für mich persönlich nochmal dieses, wir kriegen das dazu, was uns ein bisschen fehlte, nach Rückstand gegen Mannschaften, die vielleicht nicht so viel anbieten, das Spiel noch drehen zu können und brachte Bielefeld ja irgendwie auch so ein bisschen dann, ja, Lisa hat es gerade gesagt, wieder ein bisschen nach unten, also in dem Bereich, wo sie oder nachdem sie sehr, sehr gut gestartet sind, wo sie vielleicht dann doch eher sich am Ende der Saison finden, so Platz 9, 10, 11, 12. Von daher, ich fand, das war für 6,90 war es ein wichtiger Sieg und für Bielefeld war es jetzt glaube ich nicht dramatisch, denn wenn ich jetzt sage oder wenn du sagst, ihr habt vier Spiele in Folge verloren, das war gegen Hannover, die damals zumindest noch sehr gut waren, gegen Schalke, haben wir vorhin schon darüber gesprochen, richtig gute Truppe und gegen Paderborn, die sind Zweiter. Das Einzige, was nicht da rein passt, ist die Niederlage zu Hause, 3-1 gegen Fürth. Du hast es vorhin schon gesagt, das weiß bis heute keiner, wie es passiert ist. Genauso wissen wenige Leute oder haben wenige Leute damit gerechnet, dass Bielefeld jetzt zu Hause 2-0 gegen Elbersberg gewinnt. Bielefeld hatte vier Niederlagen in Folge, Elbersberg vier Siege. Das ist halt 2. Liga. Also ich glaube, man könnte bei vielen Mannschaften dieses, oder bei vielen Spielen sagen, das ist 2. Liga. Es geht einfach immer alles. Also ich denke, ihr sitzt auch alle Freitags vor Kick-Tipp und überlegt, was ihr da reinballert.
Ich tippe die 2. Liga nicht mehr. Genau aus dem Grund.
Clever.
Leute, das, was ich euch empfehlen kann. Erstens, wenn euer eigener Verein in der Liga spielt, ihr tippt nicht nach Gefälligkeiten, und seitdem ich das nicht mehr mache, stand Amina im Pokalfinale und ist aufgestiegen. Oh, okay. Das ist der Pro-Tipp. Seitdem ich nicht mehr die Ligatyppe, in der mein Verein drin spielt, läuft es super. Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Okay, Pokalfinale wird schwierig für Lisa und mich dieses Jahr.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, aber für die nächste Saison könnte man das ja mal mitnehmen. Wer weiß.
Ja, also genau das, was du ja quasi gerade bestätigt hast, ist einfach, das ist 2. Liga pur. Du weißt nie, was du kriegst. Da passieren die komischsten Sachen und es ist einfach so eine breite Masse an Vereinen, die ja für jeden Spaß zu haben sind, also wo alles in alle Richtungen gehen kann. Und da sehe ich Bielefeld auch komplett. Die haben, wie gesagt, echt gut vorgelegt, hatten dann eine Phase, wo es nicht so gut läuft. Aber ich würde mir als Bielefeld-Fan gar keine Sorgen machen. Ich hatte jetzt die Pressekonferenz noch mal gehört vom Trainer, der war sehr froh, dass er die defensive Stabilität wieder zurückgewonnen hat. Gerade gegen Elbersberg. Er hatte dann noch mal betont, ich glaube, Joel Felix war es, der zurückgekommen war, nachdem vier Buden gegen Paderborn. Und dadurch dann Fünferkette wieder spielen konnte. Und Maximilian Großer konnte dann auch ein bisschen in Richtung Spielaufbau und ein Stück nach vorne sich bewegen und orientieren. Das hat für die Umschaltmomente gesorgt, die nötig waren. Und dann hat Bielefeld einfach mal Elbersberg geschlagen. Wie gesagt, keiner hat es kommen sehen. Aber es macht diese Liga und dann natürlich auch für alle anderen Vereine, weil hat ja auch keiner Spaß dran, wenn Elbersberg alles gewinnt und wir laufen nur hinterher, macht das einfach die Liga sehr, sehr attraktiv und sehr, sehr gut.
Ja gut, das ist sehr, sehr gut.
Nein, nicht sportlich, aber einfach unterhaltungsmäßig.
Okay, ja, da gehe ich mit.
Total. Ich wollte eine Frage aber tatsächlich mal zurückspielen nach Bielefeld. Wie geht es denn unseren drei 96ern? Also Herrn Wöhl, ich weiß, der war nie so richtig 96er, aber zumindest Mumelu und Noa Joerl Sarenrenn-Bazé sind zwei. Ja, mit Danti denke ich gerne zurück und hatte sie eigentlich immer in meinem Herzen. Jetzt haben sie das 1-0 gegen Elbersberg quasi zusammen alleine vorbereitet. Was machen sie denn sonst so?
Ja, also ich fange trotzdem einmal ganz kurz bei Marius Wöhl an. Tobi, du wirst es mir verzeihen. Erstens einfach absolut Big Brain Move, als gefeiert halb Pokalheld aus der letzten Saison in der ersten Runde auszuscheiden und dann doch in der zweiten Runde zu stehen, weil man danach erst wechselt. Es ist ein Big Brain Move, sage ich wie es ist. Aber ja, ich glaube da muss man sagen, der Junge muss noch so ein bisschen reinfinden, sowohl in die 2. Liga als auch diesen Hype, der um seine Person natürlich entstanden ist, mit seiner Rückkehr, dem gerecht zu werden. Ich fand jetzt zum Beispiel, aber das Spiel gegen Elversberg zeigt wieder, warum man ihn eben auch zurückgeholt hat, wenn er auch in der richtigen Position spielt. Dann zu Munchimumulu, das ist so wirklich ein Spieler, wo ich dachte, warum holt man den jetzt zurück? Hat das mehr so auch Nostalgie-Vibes und hey, und Kniart wollte schon den ganzen Zeit? Und war das vielleicht von Mutzel auch nochmal so ein kleiner, ich sag mal, also nicht, Seitenhieb auf Markus Mann, der ja groß getönt hat im Sommer, es werden keine Spieler von Hannover nach Bielefeld wechseln? So, ob das vielleicht auch noch, aber dazu muss man einfach sagen, ich glaube, Mumulu ist unser bester Scorer, weil der einfach unfassbar viel Tempo mit reinbringt, zusammen mit Benjamin Boacsi, der als nicht gelernter Rechtsverteidiger, zum Teil einen besseren Rechtsverteidiger machte als Chris Lallard, sorry dafür, Chris, der da super arbeitet, ne? Und also das einzige Problem ist, glaube ich, noch, der kann bisher noch nicht mehr als 65 Minuten, das ist halt so ein bisschen schade, wenn du deinen mitspielstärksten Spieler halt immer nach so 60 Minuten rausnehmen musst und dann halt wirklich schon, ich sag mal in Anführungszeichen, Leistungsabfall auf der Seite siehst oder den taktisch umstellen musst, aber per se Mumulu Super, das erinnere ich mir an Basé. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich der Spieler, wo man echt wirklich sagt, hätte der halt nicht diese vielen Verletzungen gehabt. Erstens hätte Bielefeld ihn niemals in der dritten Liga zu sich holen können, das ist sowieso klar. Und zweitens wird er auch lange nicht mehr hier spielen. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns alle einig. Ich freue mich für ihn, dass er wieder zurück ist. Er hatte ja alleine durch das Pokalspiel, das Pokalfinale, glaube ich, durchaus so ein bisschen was zu knabbern. Wenn ihr es nicht gesehen habt, da kam so ein Schostenfuss. Und damit Gummo an der Stelle. Also, das hat er, glaube ich, hat ihn selber relativ lange noch beschäftigt, was hätte werden können. Aber da sieht man eben auch, der ist vielleicht nicht mehr der Schnellste, aber er bringt durchaus gute Qualität mit rein. Das war jetzt eine sehr lange Antwort auf deine Frage. Es tut mir leid, aber ich würde per se sagen, Hannover macht sich gut.
Er war mal so unfassbar schnell als der. Wahnsinn. Aber halt immer kaputt, immer verletzt. Das war wirklich... Oh Mann, dann gewechselt er nach Augsburg und es wurde nicht besser. Der tut mir nicht wirklich jedes Mal leid, wenn ich an den denke. Von daher freue ich mich sehr, dass es ihm bei euch einigermaßen gut geht.
Lisa, du wolltest gerne was noch ergänzen.
Ich frage jetzt nicht nach den Ex-Nürnbergern. Shoutout Tim Handwerker. Vermisse ich sehr, aber sehe ich, dass er sich sehr, sehr gut macht. Ich muss tatsächlich sagen, ich fand es ganz spannend, weil Tobi gerade auch noch mal so ein bisschen auf PK war. Und was ist denn so ein bisschen jetzt auch der Vibe gerade gewesen. Ich muss ja echt sagen, ich konnte total gut nachempfinden. Und das habe ich auch echt oft gelesen jetzt. Man holt irgendwie das Pokalgesicht raus. Und es ist wieder Pokalmentalität in Bielefeld, dass das immer noch was ist, was glaube ich so von außen dann auch noch mal anders irgendwie beflügelt. Dass das zumindest in meiner Bubble an Bielefeld-Fans immer noch was ist. Selbst wenn es schlecht läuft, man erinnert sich irgendwie noch an diesen schönen, schönen Erfolg. Man geht jetzt, also alle, die ich kenne, haben jetzt auch schon wieder Bock aufs Pokalspiel, auch wenn es hart wird gegen Union. Da interessiert mich gleich dein Tipp, auch wenn du sagst, du tippst keine Liga-Megapher. Aber da musst du uns gleich noch abholen. Und ich finde, das hat man tatsächlich in dem Spiel auch irgendwie gesehen. Also irgendwie kompakt verteidigt, diszipliniert gespielt, Leidenschaft war irgendwie dabei. Umschaltmomente hatte glaube ich Tobi auch schon erwähnt. Gerade so diese Mentalität, diese Tugenden, das ist es dann halt oft auch. Gerade wenn du aus so einer Negativ-Serie kommst oder wenn es vielleicht auch schon irgendwie ein bisschen Unruhe gibt an der einen oder anderen Stelle. Und da immer dieses Wort so Pokal-Gesicht, Pokal-Mentalität, das freut mich irgendwie sehr. Und das ist so ein bisschen was, wo ich auch Bielefeld und auch so die Bielefelder Bubble immer ein bisschen beneide, weil ich das Gefühl habe, das wünscht sich irgendwie jeder Club so ein bisschen für sein Team. Und ich gönne das und gucke aber gleichzeitig auch so ein bisschen neidisch hin und bin sehr, sehr gespannt jetzt auf den Mittwoch, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, wenn Bielefeld gegen Union ran muss. Da musst du den Tipp noch geben. Also da würde ich jetzt nicht raus.
Ich dachte mir das schon. Ich freue mich sehr.
Ich habe Elbersberg als Absteiger getippt. Ja, da bist du ja nicht die Einzige.
Da bist du ja nicht die Einzige. Ich glaube, also du hast mehrere Sachen gesagt. Ich fand es so interessant, dass du gesagt hast, die Pokalmentalität, wie die raus soll. Ich würde tatsächlich noch was anderes sagen. Und das ist die Gewissheit, dass man aus Krisen sich rausarbeiten kann. Weil, ich habe das schon an anderer Stelle gesagt, mir geht manchmal unter, dass Bielefeld keinen linearen Verlauf in der letzten Saison hatte. Da ging es damals schon zwischendurch mal richtig tief, gerade zum Jahresstart. Aber diese Mannschaft, die eben erstens zum größten Teil aus der Mannschaft besteht, die damals gegen den Klassen erhalt, also wirklich mit dem Rücken zur Wand ging, die Existenz stand. Das muss man einfach so klar sagen. Wer Bielefeld in die Regionalliga abgestiegen, das wäre nicht schön geworden. Und da ist eben auch ein guter Kern noch vorhanden an den Spielern. Und sie haben letztes Jahr auch keine einfache Saison gehabt. Und ich glaube, die können jetzt aber sagen, Leute, wir standen wie im Soll, wir hatten schon mal unsere 10 Punkte. Wir sind damit nicht unter den Strich gerutscht. Ich glaube, das war einfach wichtig. Und gleichzeitig konnte man sagen, wir sind immer noch Aussteiger. Für uns ist das eine ganz andere Situation, als Aussteiger mal zu sagen, wir haben eine schwäche Phase, als Absteiger, als Verein, der nach einem Jahr 3. Liga mal raus wollte. Und das einzige Problem war, dass man, du hast eben von Tugenden gesprochen und Bielefelds Tugenden in den letzten anderthalb Jahren waren. Ich fand es so witzig, dass Tobi es eben angesprochen hat. Nach einer Führung hat Bielefeld anderthalb Jahre lang nicht verloren. Also ich habe irgendwann mal eine Statistik aufgeschrieben, wie viele Führungen man hatte. Das war, da hatte man das, das letzte Mal war, glaube ich im Februar 2024 das Derby gegen Preußen Münster, wo man geführt hatte und das verloren hatte. Und danach hat man nicht einmal ein Spiel noch hinten raus verloren nach Führung. Und jetzt eben zweimal diese Spiele gehabt zu haben, einmal gegen Hannover, obwohl man da ja fast auch im Rückstand gewesen wäre, hätte Tobi Rieger nicht entschieden, den dümmsten Elfmeter aller der Geschichte zu schießen. Das muss man ja an der Stelle wirklich noch mal sagen.
Noch dümmer war der in Cottbus, also den hat der auch.
True, true. Jaja, richtig, richtig. Also gut, da wäre man da ja endlich auch schon früher in Rückstand geraten, glaube ich. Und dann gab es da ja auch noch das, bzw. da gab es auch dieses komische Abseitstor, wo es erst nicht klar war, ob Hannspiel abseits war, Ball im Tor. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Auf jeden Fall so. Und da war aber das erste Spiel, was man nach Führung hergegeben hat. Und dann gab es ja dieses absolute Freak-Spiel gegen Paderborn, wo man 2-1 geführt hat und dann innerhalb von 15 Minuten nach der Pause drei Gegentore bekommen hat und dann eben 4 zu 3 verloren hat. Aber man muss eben sagen, diese Mannschaft gibt halt nie auf. Also diese Lauf, diese intensiven Läufe, diese guten Fitnesswerte kommen eben auch davon, dass diese Mannschaft bis zur letzten Minute rennt. Ob das beim 3-1 gegen Fürth so war, ob das beim 2-1 gegen Schalke oder den Niederlagen war. Und ich glaube, das ist was, das kann man dieser Mannschaft nicht vorwerfen, dass sie eben nicht bis zur letzten Minute kämpft. Und das ist was, wo ganz viele Bielefeld-Fans auch deshalb relativ entspannt gewesen sind. Also warum, ich glaube, noch nie so entspannt auf die Niederlagen in Folge geguckt wurde, weil man einfach gesagt hat, naja, wir wissen, diese Mannschaft kann das schaffen und diese Mannschaft hat das schon geschafft. Und im Vergleich zu vor drei Jahren, wo man erstens zu dem Zeitpunkt mit weniger Punkten da stand und zweitens eine ganz, ganz andere Mannschaftsgebilde hatte damals, können das, glaube ich, viele Bielefeld-Fans auch richtig einordnen. Aber es war halt trotzdem einfach so, du hast das angesprochen, diese Defensive, die war halt, was so ein Prunkspruch war, die stand halt unter Beschuss und da war es schon gut. Und dazu muss man sagen, also ein maximgroßer Spiel, jetzt quasi Sechser, einfach da muss man so ein bisschen auf Kaderplanung gehen, hat man da eventuell Fehler gemacht. Man hat irgendwie eigentlich drei Innenverteidiger zur Verfügung, das ist ein bisschen wenig auf langen Gesicht gesehen, weil Jonathan Norby, den man eben auch noch geholt hat, eher so für die neu gegründete U21 spielt. Und man hat aber einen viel größeren Ausfall und das ist Stefano Russo, der sich ja im Spiel gegen Hannover verletzt hat. Und der ist das Bindeglied dieser Mannschaft. Nehmt Mal Corbus, ist das der Spieler, wo ich bis heute sage, es ist unfassbar wichtig, dass die beiden so schnell in der 2. Liga angekommen sind. Und da sage ich auch bis heute, mein Respekt. Ich glaube, Mal Corbus läuft jedes Spiel über 13 km. Ich würde mich einfach weigern, aber gut, deshalb mache ich auch keinen Profisport. Also das noch, glaube ich, zusammengesammt. Joel Felix war verletzt, Tim Handwerker verletzt, Noah Sarangin-Bazé. Mit Ul Drikes hast du einen Stürmer, der hoffentlich jetzt vielleicht zum Ende des Jahres nochmal kurz wiederkommt, aber sonst eben auch nochmal eine Option für vorne hast. Vielleicht findet Marvin Melem auch irgendwann seine Rolle in diesem Kader. Also ich würde sagen, und das habe ich, glaube ich, schon Anfang der Saison gesagt, in diesem Kader ist Potenzial nach oben. Und ich sage das immer wieder gerne, wenn ein Trainer gezeigt hat, dass er das aus Spielern rausholen kann, dann ist das mitgeklärt. So, jetzt habe ich doch ein Monologe gehalten, es tut mir leid.
Jetzt fehlt nur noch dein Tipp.
Danke.
Hast du auch gemerkt, Tobi?
Ja, so. Das Ding ist, ich mache mir das jetzt einfach, weil Grüße gehen raus an die Kolleginnen vom RWB, mit denen habe ich heute morgen gesprochen vor dem Pokalspiel. Und da musste ich auch tippen, die haben einen Nein nicht gelten lassen. Und ich habe einfach gesagt, 1-0 Bielefeld. Wie ist mir vollkommen egal, 1-0 Bielefeld, gerne in 90 Minuten. 20, 45 Spiele gehören abgeschafft im Winter. Es ist jetzt seit ungefähr acht Stunden dunkel. Ich möchte da einfach schnell wieder raus. Und in Berlin braucht man ja auch so ein bisschen, bis man da wieder aus den Stadien raus ist.
Ich glaube, da rätst du offene Türen ein. Ich werde am Mittwoch bei der Sportshow arbeiten. Und da ist das die gleiche Devise, wenn der Klub nicht spielt. Am besten nach 90 Minuten durch. Wer gewinnt, na ja, schauen wir mal. Aber 1-0, ich bin froh, dass du dich zum Tipp hast überzeugen lassen.
Ja, ja.
Ihr seid schuld, ne? Also wir wissen alle, der RBB und ihr beide seid schuld. Wenn das nicht klappt, weil ihr habt mich gezwungen. Und das finde ich nicht nett.
Aber der RBB war schon vor uns. Also guck mal, wir haben es jetzt nur noch mal so ausgenutzt. Ich wusste es nicht, aber...
So oder so. Viel wichtiger wird danach das Auswahlspiel in Darmstadt und zu Hause gegen Karlsruhe. Und da sage ich ja einfach mal ganz uneigennützlich, ich hoffe, wir sehen da mehr von dem Gesicht gegen Elbersberg als von dem Gesicht gegen Schalke Hannover. Und Paderborn, das ist meine Meinung dazu, aber ich habe da vollstes Vertrauen. Dann springen wir zu unserem letzten Team. Und ich sage das hier nochmal, es mag Leute vielleicht ein wenig komisch vorkommen, wenn sie den Titel dieser Sendung gelesen haben und dachten, warum zum Henga kommt Hannover 96 hier drin vor. Man steht nämlich schließlich auf Platz 4, hat 20 Punkte, 18 zu 13 Tore, 6 Siege, 2 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlagen. In der Formtabelle steht man auf Platz 6. Dazu muss ich sagen, vor diesem Spieltag stand man da ein bisschen niedriger da. Und das war so ein bisschen der Grund, warum wir uns angeguckt haben, was ist eigentlich nach der Niederlage gegen Hertha so passiert. Da gab es so eine leichte Schwächephase. Also man hatte jetzt zuletzt eine 0-3, also vor dem Derbysieg 0-3 gegen Schalke, Unentschieden gegen Fürth, zwar ein Sieg gegen Nürnberg, aber auch ein Unentschieden gegen Dresden. Also da gab es so eine Schwächephase. Aber, Tobi, bevor wir gleich über das Derby sprechen, würdest du das als leichte Schwächephase bezeichnen oder würdest du einfach sagen, das hat was mit dem Grundlevel der Liga zu tun?
Könnte man darauf schieben. Ich fand, es war eine Schwächephase. Ich fand, es war auch keine wirklich coole Zeit, weil man ist ja wirklich gestartet wie verrückt, mit vier Spielen, vier Siegen. Wir hatten zwischendurch vier Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz zwei. Ganz, ganz absurdes Gefühl nach vier Spieltagen. Und dann, du hast es angesprochen, diese beiden Heimspiele, es war zu Hause gegen Hertha, es war zu Hause gegen Schalke, jeweils 0 zu 3. Das tut schon weh und natürlich bleibt sowas irgendwie auch noch ein Stück mehr hängen bei der Breite der Fans, weil natürlich einfach 30.000, 40.000 im Stadion sind. Also, wenn du dann so ein 2-2 da irgendwie in Fürth auf dem Sonntag-Nametag hast, ist das vielleicht am Montag bei dem einen oder anderen auch wieder vergessen. Klammer auf, bei mir nicht. Aber diese beiden Auswärtsspiele, 2-2, kamen dann noch dazu. Und dann, okay, der Sieg gegen Bielefeld war dabei. Der hat das so ein bisschen aufgelockert, das Ganze. Aber wir haben ja, du hast es gerade schon angedeutet, wir haben beschlossen, welche Vereine wir reinnehmen und wie wir das Ganze machen, bevor der Spieltag gegen jetzt Braunschweig am Sonntag war. Und ich habe ganz klar gesagt, wenn wir das nicht gewinnen, dann könnte es sein, dass ich hier etwas polterhaft durch die Gegend erlichte. So ist es jetzt, dass ich schon sagen kann, wir haben uns wieder gefangen. Es ist alles erstmal ganz gut. Dieses wichtige Derby, was wir sehr, sehr lange nicht mehr gewonnen haben, zumindest nicht mehr mit Fans. Ich war mit vier Leuten unterwegs und ich glaube, ich war der Einzige, der einen Auswärts-Derby-Sieg in seinem Leben gesehen hat. Wir sind alle nicht 13 und 14, sondern– Krass! Wer es bei YouTube sieht, ist, wir sind in der Regel über 40 oder zumindest Ende 30. Das liegt daran, dass der letzte Sieg 2021 unter Corona-Bedingungen war. Da war gar keiner im Stadion. Der Sieg davor war dann Ende der 90er in der 3. Liga. Seitdem gab es keinen Auswärts-Sieg mehr. Es gab auch wirklich wenige Spiele, das muss man dazu sagen. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das der ewig junge Schlager ist und man immer wieder gegeneinander spielt. Aber trotzdem, das zeigt schon, wie wichtig dieser Sieg war für viele Leute, die da im Stadion waren und teilweise auch einfach für Leute, die schon deutlich älter sind als 2021, 2022. Denn das war keine Selbstverständlichkeit am Sonntag.
Bevor wir da generell noch mehr in den Deep Dive gehen, eine ganz kurze Frage an Lisa. Hat dich das so ein bisschen überrascht zu sehen, dass Hannover da so ein bisschen nachgelassen hat?
Auf der einen Seite ja. Auf der anderen Seite, ehrlicherweise auch nicht. Tobi hatte das vorhin schon mal so ganz gut angerissen.
Es ist halt diese 2.
Liga. Und ich finde es so schwierig, sich da wirklich schon festzulegen. Also ich finde auch Tipps zum Beispiel immer ganz schlimm. Ich weiß noch, als wir hier tippen mussten vor der Saison. Deswegen habe ich immer das Gefühl, es hat eigentlich jeder mal so einen Ausreißer nach oben, aber dann auch mal so einen Ausreißer nach unten. Es gibt irgendwie kaum ein Team, das wirklich konstant mitspielt. Sei es dann einfach durch individuelle Fehler, sei es durch Verletzungen. Deswegen hat mich das ein bisschen überrascht in der Situation. Also gerade das härtere Spiel, ehrlicherweise. Aber andererseits auch wieder nicht, weil es dann doch wieder diese irre 2. Liga ist, die ich total liebe, die mich auch mal wahnsinnig macht. Und wo ich immer so denke, boah, wenn man keinen Verein in der 2. Liga hat, dann macht es eigentlich jeden Spieltag Bock, dazu zu gucken, weil halt immer mal wieder so eine Wundertüte drin steckt. Und ich finde, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen auch da an der ein oder anderen Stelle passiert. Deswegen war ich eher überrascht, dass es so, so gut am Anfang losging. Das war, glaube ich, auch nicht so ganz klar. Also habe ich auch noch gerade so ein bisschen rekapituliert vor der Folge. Wir hatten ja auch schon über Hannover mal gesprochen. Und auch, was bringt denn jetzt Christian Tietz jetzt mit? Und wie passt das zusammen? Ich fand auch den Kader ehrlicherweise super spannend. Da kann Tobi bestimmt auch an der ein oder anderen Stelle noch deutlich tiefer reingehen als ich, weil ich das total spannend fand. Welche Spieler sind da so gekommen? Aus welchen Ligen sind die? Ich kannte ehrlicherweise ungefähr niemanden, der da jetzt dazu kam. Und ich glaube, es ging nicht nur mir so. Nicht nur, weil ich jetzt nicht Hannover-Ultra bin, sondern ich glaube, ganz viele, die die 2. Liga verfolgen, weil sie halt einen Club in der 2. Liga haben, haben so ein Basic-Wissen über die anderen Teams oder kennen dann auch den ein oder anderen Spieler. Und ich muss echt sagen, Hannover war für mich ein bisschen so eine Black Box, wer da jetzt dazu gekommen ist und auch wie das läuft. Und ich finde es total spannend und auch ein Stück weit beneidenswert, wie gut das schon sich gefunden hat, ehrlicherweise, in Hannover. Aber gerne Tobi, als Experte, so ein bisschen dein Blick aufs Derby, aber auch auf Hannover generell, wie du es bewerten würdest vielleicht.
Fangen wir vielleicht mit dem Generellen mal an. Ja, mir ging das ähnlich wie dir, dass ich zumindest bei den meisten Spielern erstmal transfermarkt.de oder sonstige Seiten anschmeißen musste, um zu gucken, mit wem wir es denn da jetzt zu tun haben. Es hat sogar so weit geführt, dass ich eine Excel-Tabelle angeschmissen habe, wo ich so die Key-Facts mir eingetragen habe. Es waren glaube ich am Ende 17 oder 18 Spieler, die wir verpflichtet haben. Und trotz allem, oder am meisten hat mich dann eigentlich gewundert, dass wir trotzdem sehr weit oben von vielen gerankt wurden vor der Saison. Ich habe auch, ich glaube, wir haben ja diese Kacheln hier beim Rasenfunk rausgehauen. Da habe ich gesagt, komm, mache ich mit. Wenn man nicht dran glaubt, dann kann es ja auch nicht passieren. Wir werden schon aufsteigen. Aber eigentlich, also realistisch betrachtet, ein neuer Trainer, so viele neue Spieler, die komplette Achse. Wir müssen überlegen, letztes Jahr Ron-Robert Zieler im Tor, Halzenberg in der Innenverteidigung, Neumann abgegeben nach England. Das ist und vorne Trezoldi, jetzt hätte ich fast seinen Namen vergessen, um Gottes Willen. Also wir haben einfach auch wirklich einen großen, großen Cut im Kader gehabt und haben dafür Spieler geholt, die, wie gesagt, also klar, Neubauer von Elbersberg, das war natürlich ein Begriff, den haben wir dann ein Jahr davor da auf der linken Seite schon rumzaubern gesehen, oder auch die beiden Kieler mit Pichler und Sterner, auch die wusste man, aber wenn es dann irgendwie nach Südafrika geht oder nach Japan in die 2. Liga, sorry, bin ich echt raus, zumindest was so das vorherige Wissen angeht. Und dann hatten wir diese vier Spiele und sind in die Saison reingekommen und es klappte einfach alles. Also dieser Tits-Fußball war etwas, was ich glaube ich so diese ersten vier Spiele noch nie in Hannover gesehen habe. Vielleicht um den Bogen zurückzuschlagen, dass wir so wilden Fußball gespielt haben Ende der 90er, als wir dann von der 3. in die 2. Liga aufgestiegen sind. Aber da waren wir einfach, da hatten wir so einen Unfall von sich gerade.
Gott, ich hatte so Angst, was du jetzt sagst. Ich habe mir Kusslomka schon in meinem Kopf mache.
Ja, das war sicherlich auch ein ganz besonderer Fußball. Also die erste Zeit mit Slomka, das war schon wild und auch gut in Europa. Da hatten wir schon Spaß. Aber dass wir wirklich, dass wir so was Besonderes hatten, wo man sich glaube ich auch lange daran erinnern kann. Ich habe es vergessen, wir haben ja mit Fronsek und Kenan Kutschak und wie sie alle heißen, haben wir uns hier trainieren lassen. Und Thomas Doil, also, Gott des Willen.
Das vergesse ich immer.
Ja, und Thomas Doil, hätte ich auch gar nicht mehr.
Das ist noch nicht das Schlimmste, Gott sei Dank vergesse ich auch viel. Und das ist auch gar nicht so schlecht. Deshalb waren diese ersten vier Spieltage, es war, ohne Scheiß, es war ein Rausch. Ich dachte, wie es ist, es war ein kompletter Rausch. Das sah spannend aus, das war toll. Der Trainer hat sich mit 9 Torwart gewünscht. Der hat die Ziele auch ein Stück weit verdrängt. Oder Ziele ist freiwillig gegangen. Oder Köln war attraktiver. Ich habe keine Ahnung, es ist egal, wie man das am Ende formuliert. Auf jeden Fall hatten wir 0 auf einmal im Tor stehen. Und der ist dann der fünfte oder sechste Innenverteidiger, weil der Vogelwild durch die Gegend läuft, aber eine Ballbehandlung hat. Da kann sich der ein oder andere Stürmer und Mittelfeldspieler sicherlich noch eine Scheibe von abschneiden. Und dann haben wir einfach einen komplett anderen Fußball gesehen. Es wird nicht mehr nach vorne gebolzt oder Abschläge gemacht. Es wird alles spielerisch von hinten aufgebaut. Und wenn der Gegner mit 9 Spielern auf unsere Abwehrreihe zu presst, dann wird immer noch nicht gebolzt. Dann wird trotzdem versucht, das spielerisch zu lösen. Dann kommen wir wieder zum Alter. Ich bin in einem Alter, das vertrage ich nicht so gut. Also das ist wirklich...
Da trägt man in keinem Alter.
Es ist der... Also das sind alles Sachen, die haben mich... Ich war darauf nicht vorbereitet, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Es war die letzten Jahre anders. Und es ist jetzt einfach, dass diese Innenverteidiger und Enzo Leopold rückt meistens noch ein Stück zurück, um den Ball entgegenzunehmen und das Spiel wieder aufzubauen. Dass die eine Ballsicherheit haben, zumindest meistens, die mich erfreut, aber auch mich auch ein bisschen erschreckt. Wenn es da nicht klappt, dann kommen wir in Probleme, ist klar. Haben wir glaube ich auch schon ein, zwei Gegentore gefressen. Es ist ein Risiko, dass es immer mit dabei ist. Jetzt geht das ganz bewusst ein. Auch Gott sei Dank. Ich hoffe, dass die Spieler nicht das Selbstvertrauen verlieren, wenn sie Fehler machen. Ich hoffe, dass sie in der Mannschaft gestärkt werden, dass sie als Kollektiv sagen, wir wollen das so spielen, wir sind davon überzeugt, das ist okay. Du darfst dann auch mal einen Fehler machen, weil wenn du einen Fehler machst, ist das Ding in der Regel durch. Also dann stehen die Gegner mit zwei Leuten vor dem Tor und dann ist das Tor da. Ich fluche da ab und zu drüber. Ich fluche da auch teilweise sehr laut drüber, aber es ist schon sehr beeindruckend und macht super viel Spaß, das Ganze zu sehen. Und auch wenn es zwischendurch mal ein bisschen geruppelt hat, Gott sei Dank im Derby dann auch dazu geführt, dass alles gut war und dass das funktioniert hat.
Ja, dann lass uns einmal ganz kurz einen Blick auf dieses Derby werfen. Am Ende war es eben ein 3 zu 0-Sieg gegen Eintracht Braunschalk. Du hast es eben schon gesagt. Ich würde aber schon sagen, begünstigt durch den frühen Platzverweis von Yadimchi. Generell Platzverweise bei Eintracht Braunschalk ein Problem. Da könnt ihr nochmal reinhören, was Anna dazu sagt. Ich glaube, es ist die fünfte rote Karte in zehn Spielen. Es ist sehr interessant, dass Yadimchi sich heute, glaube ich, entschuldigt hat generell bei seinen Mitspielern, bei seinem Trainerteam und bei seinen Fans. Bei Tomiak hat er sich nie entschuldigt.
Also, wir sind uns doch einig, dass Tomiak ihm irgendeine Geschichte auf dem Platz erzählt hat, oder? Also, es gab vor so ein Kopfball-Duell, da hatte Tomiak nach einer Ecke ein Kopfball-Duell gewonnen gegen ihn. Vielleicht hat er ihm da schon ein bisschen Trash-Talk ins Ohr genuschelt. Aber so reagierst du doch nicht, wenn alles ein normales Fußballspiel ist. Da muss der Derby hin oder her so...
Selbst für einen Derby war das krass, ja.
Vor allem, also, ehrlich gesagt, ich sage das an der Stelle auch nochmal, Tätlichkeiten in Zeiten von VHR sind für mich das Dürmste, was du machen kannst. Also klar, Tomiak macht da auch relativ viel raus. Also, ich möchte nicht bezweifeln, dass so ein Griff an die Kehle nicht angenehm ist, aber er macht da gut, brauchen wir nicht weiter diskutieren.
Kann ich ganz kurz zurückfragen zu dem Thema? Weil im Stadion konnte ich es gar nicht sehen. Im Stadion sah es so aus, als wenn er ihm so an der Brust rumfummelt. Das war aber offensichtlich nicht der Fall. Dann habe ich die Wiederholung gesehen, da konnte man sogar so ein bisschen sehen, dass da so auf der roten Haut so Fingerabdrücke zu sehen waren am Hals. Okay, aber Tomiak stand doch die ganze Zeit und dann auf einmal lager.
Ja, genau.
So eine Luft, die verschwand nach 30 Sekunden. Das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden.
Ja, genau. Also wahrscheinlich um drauf aufmerksam machen, um das so ein bisschen dem Schiedsrichter auch nochmal zur Kenntnis zu machen. Hallo, hier ist was passiert. Gut, da brauchen wir nicht weiter zu diskutieren. Also, das klingt jetzt ein bisschen doof. Ich wäre sehr gespannt gewesen, wie dieses Spiel weitergelaufen wäre. Hätte man das 11 gegen 11 zu Ende gespielt? Ich würde davon, also man muss ja trotzdem sagen, Hannover hat sich schon nicht schwer getan, aber das Tor zu treffen war doch erst so ein kleines Problem. Da wäre ich schon mal gespannt gewesen, wie es gelaufen wäre, wenn da halt Gleichzahl auf dem Platz gestanden hätte. Aber trotzdem muss man sagen, die Fehler, die Braunschweig gemacht haben, ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass das mit einem Mann mehr nicht dazu geführt hat, weil einfach die Basics an Fehlern zu machen, Hannover da laufen zu lassen, Hannover kommen zu lassen, das war halt einfach nicht besonders clever. Again, ich verweise euch da gerne auf Annas Aussagen, zuletzt die, glaube ich, sowieso nicht generell. Heiner Backhaus, großer Fan ist an der Stelle. Man muss, glaube ich, sagen, einfach nachdem man eben diese Spiele gegen Fürth und gegen Dresden hatte, mit zwei Teams, die weiter unten stehen, eben jetzt gegen Braunschweig, dann doch noch mal gegen einen– ja, es ist nicht respektlos gemeint– aber in allen Formen des Kaders, eigentlich schwächeren Teams, eben doch das relativ deutlich zu machen, nach dieser 0-3-Niederlage gegen Schalke. Ich glaube, das war ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Sieg, einfach in der Gesamtkonstellation.
Absolut. Und ich teile dein Interesse– also, das teile ich persönlich nicht, aber ich weiß, dass es ein anderes Spiel gewesen wäre, wenn diese rote Karte nicht gekommen wäre. Wie gesagt, ich wäre nicht daran interessiert gewesen, das zu erfahren, aber ich stelle es mir durchaus auch vor, dass das schwieriger geworden wäre für 96 gegen dann Elfmann, beziehungsweise es gab ja auch die andere Alternative, und da müssen wir jetzt mal ganz klar Christian Titz loben, der verhindert hat, dass es 10 gegen 10 ist. Also Bundu hatte schon eine gelbe Karte, hatte dann eine Szene, die ja, so la la. Also ich hatte das Gefühl, der Schiri hat ihm noch die allerletzte Chance gegeben. Und dann als Trainer in der 45. Minute, also vor der Halbzeit, zu sagen, ich nehme dich raus. Alle wussten, es gibt so ein paar Minuten Nachspielzeit, wegen Unterbrechung, wegen kleines Feuerchen. Ist natürlich, grundsätzlich gibt es immer die Aussage, das ist die Höchststrafe, wenn du in der ersten Halbzeit ausgewechselt wirst, genauso wie wenn du eingewechselt und dann wieder ausgewechselt wirst. Aber in dem Fall war es einfach, das war Christian Titz Masterclass. Das war genau der richtige Moment, ich glaube, Bundu hätte keine Sekunde länger spielen dürfen. Neben dem Trainer haben zwei Leute, die in dieser Szene in meinen Augen sehr gut reagiert haben. Das eine war Enzo Leopold, der Kapitän, der sofort zu Bundu hingegangen ist, als es hieß, du musst runter. Der ihm was auch immer gesagt hat, aber zumindest ihm gezeigt hat, dass es richtig war, du hast ein gutes Spiel gemacht. Er hatte ja das Tor vorbereitet, zum 1-0 war das. Genau das war das 1-0, was er vorbereitet hatte. Der zweite war Virgil Gieta, unser Innenverteidiger, der sich umgedreht hat und dann Richtung Gäste block, die gerade irgendwas gesungen haben, angezeigt hat, dass sie applaudieren sollen für Bundu. Das war so eine Szene, die mich sehr glücklich gestimmt hat und gezeigt hat, die Mannschaft, die denken mit, die haben ein bisschen Fingerspitzengefühl, die wissen, was man in solchen Situationen machen muss, damit Bundu jetzt nicht denkt, oh Scheiße, ich werde ausgewechselt in der ersten Halbzeit, ich werde irgendwie bestraft oder so. Das Ganze mit Titz und Bundu noch hinterher, als er dann rausgenommen hat, haben sie noch kurz gesprochen. Es sah sehr harmonisch aus, das Ganze. Das war einer der vielen Punkte, die mir an dem Tag sehr gut gefallen haben.
Generell, wir kommen gleich noch darauf zu sprechen, warum dieses Derby in vielerlei Hinsicht ein besonderes war. Aber ich bin jetzt tatsächlich sehr gespannt, denn man hat ein durchaus interessantes Programm vor sich. Auswärts bei der SVE, zu Hause gegen Darmstadt oder auswärts bei Paderborn. Ich sage mal so, ich habe eben bei Bielefeld gesagt, ich hoffe, wir sehen ein anderes Gesicht. Ich würde mal sagen, du würdest das unterschreiten, wenn ich sage, du möchtest auch ein anderes Gesicht gegen diese 3 Vereine als das, was man gegen Schalke gezeigt hat.
Also Elvesberg, finde ich, kann nach 4 Siegen, können sie jetzt ja auch 4 mal verlieren. Also Bielefeld legt vor und wir machen nach, wäre ich voll und ganz fein. Aber grundsätzlich hast du natürlich recht, das ist ein Brett. Und genau deshalb war es ja auch mega, mega wichtig, jetzt diese drei Punkte mitzunehmen. Weil also Gesamtsituation wäre hoch problematisch gewesen, wenn wir nicht gewonnen hätten und wenn wir verloren hätten, brauchen wir gar nicht drüber zu reden. Da gab es dann Trainer, die auf dem Zaun standen mit Megafon und versucht haben, die Menge zu beruhigen. Also da war ich Christian Titz nicht, nicht, dass ich ihm das nicht zutraue, aber das wäre halt etwas, oh Gott, das wäre wirklich fürchterlich gewesen. Und jetzt, ja, jetzt hat man gezeigt, dass man diesen Charakter hat, dieses Derby zu gewinnen. Das ist sehr gut gewesen. Und jetzt muss man halt auch zeigen, dass man in der Tabelle Vereine, die oben stehen, Eversberg, steht noch vor uns. Ich blicke ein bisschen runter. Darmstadt ist zwei Punkte hinter uns. Paderborn ist drei Punkte vor uns. Und Karlsruhe ist wiederum zwei Punkte hinter uns. Also das ist eigentlich alles, das ist unsere Kategorie. Und jetzt sind das vier Spiele. Wenn man danach weiterhin vierter ist, dann hat man nicht viel falsch gemacht. Ich denke, das sollte das Ziel sein. Ob das klappt, wird man sehen. Wie das so mit dem Ball im Strafraum und den kurzen Pässen und dem mutigen Spielaufbau, in welche Richtung sich das so entwickelt.
Eine letzte Frage habe ich noch, bevor wir dann auf Daniela Behrens zu sprechen kommen. Also beziehungsweise von außen habe ich das Gefühl, dass die Beziehung zwischen Verein und Mannschaft und Fans unverein, ehrlich gesagt, so gut ist wie lange nicht mehr. Also das Stadion ist voll, gut auswärts hatte man glaube ich immer einen ganz guten Mob dabei, aber man hat irgendwie generell das Gefühl, die Laune ist ganz gut, vielleicht die Toleranzschwelle auch einfach ein bisschen höher gesetzt in dem Sinne, dass man vielleicht der Mannschaft ein bisschen mehr Zeit gibt, als wäre das jetzt eben noch letztes Jahr unter Leitl gewesen. Würdest du mir das zustimmen? Würdest du mir das zustimmen oder ist das ein Trugschluss von außen?
Nee, glaube ich schon. Ich glaube, das stimmt ein Stück weit. Neben dieser ganzen sportlichen Sache, wo man ja erstmal der Mannschaft Zeit geben sollte und das Gefühl habe ich auch, wird ihr gegeben. Die vollen Stadien, weiß nicht, ob es immer nur an den Heimfans gelegen hat. Also klar, die Nordkurve, der harte Kern, der ist immer da, gar keine Frage. Dann gibt es auf der Westtribüne auch einen Bereich, der immer gut bis sehr gut verkauft ist. Aber dass dann am Ende eine Zahl ist, die größer ist als 45.000, das geht in der Regel in Hannover, zumindest in der 2. Liga nicht ohne den Gastverein. Bielefeld war da, Schalke, ich meine, guck, wer da war, das ist ja, Lautern war da, Magdeburg ist auch nicht so weit weg von Hannover, Hertha war da. Also das sind alles Vereine, die dann auch ordentlich mitbringen und am Ende dafür sorgen, dass die Zahl, ich glaube, wir haben jetzt einen Schnitt von 47.000 oder so. Das ist Wahnsinn. Also klar, der sportliche Erfolg tut dann auch so ein bisschen seinen Teil dazu. Wir haben diese Geschichte, ich weiß nicht, inwieweit das mitbekommen wurde. Die Sitze sollen verändert werden im nächsten Jahr. Die Farbe der Sitze, das war ja immer noch dieses alte, hässliche Blau, was eigentlich gar nichts mit Hannover 96 zu tun hat, aber die gab es, soweit ich gehört habe, mal recht kostengünstig im Einkauf, als das Stadion gebaut wurde. Jetzt hat man gesagt, man möchte gerne investieren und möchte gerne auch, dass das Stadion so aussieht, wie es aussehen soll. Da gab es eine Abstimmung, da hat man die Fans mitgenommen, hat nicht einfach was entschieden, sondern hat gefragt, hier sind 5 Vorschläge. Ich meine, am Ende, ich weiß bis heute nicht mehr, was die Unterschiede waren, wo jetzt oben, unten, egal. Aber auch das macht einen guten Eindruck und man darf es wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht unterschlagen. Martin Kind, der für viele das Problem bei Hannover 96 ist, hatte sich längererfristig aus der Öffentlichkeit zurückgezogen, so wie ich jetzt gehört habe, aus gesundheitlichen Gründen. Und ich habe das Gefühl, wenn Martin Kind nicht viel gefragt wird, bzw. nicht oft irgendwelche Zitate von ihm in der Zeitung stehen, egal wie viel Fundament die vielleicht haben oder wie sinnig die auch sein mögen, es ist völlig egal. Die Leute regen sich einfach weniger auf, wenn man weniger von ihm liest, wenn man Hannover 96. Das ist einfach so. Egal, welche Seite. Wenn er was sagt, was irgendwem nicht gefällt und irgendwem doch, dann regen sich zumindest eine Hälfte, und dann regen sich die eine Hälfte über die andere Hälfte. Es ist einfach, und ich mache das hier sehr lange, es ist einfach so ein leidiges Thema. Deshalb war es tatsächlich so seit Sommer ganz chillig und nett.
Wie sehr froh bist du, dass du ausnahmsweise mal nicht wieder die gesellschaftliche oder gesellschaftliche Organisation von Hannover 96 hier aussehen musstest. Ich habe sie immer griffbereit. Ich gehe davon aus sehr froh. Ich bin es auf jeden Fall, weil jedes Mal, wenn ich versuche, mir das durchzulesen und zu verstehen, dass diese Nampsen in meinem Gehirn keine Gruppe haben.
Es wird die Zeit kommen, wo das wieder ein Thema wird, wenn es um 50 plus 1 und eine halbe Stunde um 50 plus 1 geht. Gar keine Frage, dann wird auch Hannover wieder ganz vorne in der Geschichte diskutiert werden. Aber aktuell ist es ja auch so ein Thema, wo die meisten sich einfach auch ungern zu rühren, also allen voran von denen, die was zu entscheiden haben. Im Moment ist es so, wie es ist. Ich bin mit der Gesamtsituation zufrieden.
Lisa, Entschuldige bitte, aber wir haben noch ein letztes Thema, und das ist die Stadion-Auslastung bei Derbys. Tobi, ich würde einfach mal ganz grob anfangen, und du fängst mich bitte ein bzw. korrigierst mich. Also, es gab ja zuletzt mehrere Male Derbys, eigentlich vor allem ohne organisierte Fanszenen, sowohl heim- als auch auswärts, um Gottes willen. Also zum Teil waren natürlich trotzdem Fans im Stadion. Ich rede jetzt explizit von organisierten Fanszenen, weil sie eben ja nicht mitgehen wollten, was Daniela Behrens als Innenminister von Niedersachsen da so wollte. Das war jetzt ein Konzept auf Bewährung, deshalb gab es eigentlich eine nahezu voll besetzte Stadion. Es gab eine große, also du kannst es gerne gleich näher deine Eindrücke aus dem Stadion beschreiben, es gab eben alle möglichen Vorrichtungen, um da, ich glaube Bälle auf dem Rasen etc., irgendwelches Aufeinanderprallen von gegnerischen Fanszenen zu verhindern. Genau, jetzt war eben der Gästeblog ausverkauft. Es gab ein geschärftes Sicherheitskonzept für das Spiel, die Einlasskontrollen sollten noch strenger sein, es gab mehr Ordner und das Einzige, was es nicht gab, war ein streng personalisiertes Ticket zu Gästefans, die wurde, also das war eine Forderung der Polizei und da haben aber beide Clubs gesagt, nee, das wollen wir nicht. So, jetzt, das ist der grobe Rahmen. Magst du vielleicht einmal sagen, was ist denn überhaupt der Standpunkt der Vereine, der Fans und was ist denn das Problem von Daniela Behrens? Vorsichtig aus. Ich glaube, das wird zu…
Fangen wir einfach hinten an. Daniela Behrens hatte sich, nachdem, jetzt muss ich kurz überlegen, das muss 2024, also nicht in der letzten Saison, da war ohne Zuschauer, sondern davor. Es gab ja noch weiter davor, gab es ja mal diese Situation, dass im Gästeblog, also wo Hannover drin war, Rauchbomben, der Heimmannschaft gezündet wurden, dann gab es im Rückspiel natürlich die Angst der Gäste, dass das auch der Fall ist, dann haben sie da die halbe Sitzbänke auseinandergebaut. Also es schaukelte sich mit fragwürdigen Aktionen ein bisschen hoch und gipfelte dann, meiner Meinung nach, in dem Auswärtsspiel von Hannover in Braunschweig, wo vor dem Gästeblog, ich glaube, dass es tatsächlich auch nichts Ungewöhnliches ist, dass der Gästeblog so ein bisschen so eingezäunt ist mit so einem Netz. Das gibt es teilweise sogar über die ganze Hintertortribüne in einem oder anderen Stadion. Und da war es jetzt natürlich um den Gästeblog, wo Hannover drin war. Da, also muss man ganz klar sagen, da wurden Grenzen überschritten von der 96 Auswärtsfans. Da wurde das Netz herangezogen. Da wurden durch das Netz Raketen in den Heimbereich geschossen auf Menschen, die da saßen. Egal, wo die jetzt herkamen, ob das Braunschweiger, Kieler oder Menschen mit Kindern. Scheißegal, man schießt nicht mit Raketen auf Menschenpunkt. Das war eine Grenze, die überschritten war. Das andere war, weil es von der Außenwirkung ein Komplettes Desaster ist, wenn du 500 Sitze anzündest. Das sieht auch nicht gut aus, wenn wirklich so 2-3 Meter hohe... Das ist Käse, das hat man gemacht. Das hat Frau Behrens, die Innenministerin, die früher noch, glaube ich, die Gesundheitsministerin oder so, was in Niedersachsen war, hat das auf den Plan gerufen und sie wollte das nutzen, um, also ich gehe mal davon aus, sich ein bisschen ins Gespräch zu bringen, ihr Profil zu schärfen, hat gesagt, da müssen wir hart durchgreifen, ihr könnt euch das vorstellen, wie das alles so ist. Die Suche ist nicht von der Partei, die ihr jetzt gerade denkt, sondern ist tatsächlich von der SPD, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Und die wollte da hart durchgreifen und hat gesagt, das geht so nicht, wir müssen Gäste-Fans ausschließen, wir müssen, wir müssen, wir müssen. Und dann ging es in der letzten Saison darum, dass maximal die Hälfte oder ich glaube 60 Prozent, also auf jeden Fall nicht die volle Auslastung im Gästeblog ist. Und da kommen wir dann zu dem Thema, was wollen die Fans, die wollen natürlich einen vollen Gästeblog. Da sind sich beide Seiten auch einig. Die Regel war nun, es gibt nur einen gewissen Anteil. Dementsprechend hat erst Braunschweig in Hannover gesagt, wir kommen nicht und dann war es andersrum. Ich kriege es auch gar nicht mehr zusammen. Wir waren erst auswärts nicht da und dann waren die bei uns nicht da. Wie gesagt, alles auf die organisierte Fanszene bezogen. So ein paar Leute waren natürlich trotzdem da. Man konnte tatsächlich mal einfach Karten kriegen fürs Derby. Das heißt, die Fans wollen natürlich volle Auslastung in den Blöcken. Jetzt ging es auf unser Spiel am letzten Wochenende zu. Frau Behrens hatte vorher groß angekündigt, dass das wieder so wird wie letztes Jahr. Dann wurde es ein bisschen ruhiger in der ganzen Geschichte und man hörte lange nichts. Klar, wir wissen alle, da wird im Hintergrund viel diskutiert und gemacht und getan. Dann gab es, das muss ich lügen, 2 Monate oder 1,5 Monate vor dem Spiel, äußerte sich Eintracht Braunschweig als Verein und hat gesagt, man hat uns gebeten, wir sollen personalisierte Tickets machen und das können wir nicht. Das können wir nicht und das wollen wir nicht. Es ist einfach nicht machbar, den Gästeblock mit personalisierten Tickets. Der Einlass, da passen 2.000, 2.500 Leute rein. Wenn du die personalisiert kontrollierst, der Tag ist vorbei, es funktioniert einfach nicht. Ich weiß nicht, was alles im Hintergrund passiert ist. Es ist sicherlich viel passiert. Man hat miteinander gesprochen und Ende vom Lead war tatsächlich Vollauslastung für den Gästeblock, das heißt, das, was die Fans haben wollten. Und das, was die Innenministerin haben wollte, hat man ihr wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen gegeben mit einem verschärften, erhöhten Sicherheitskonzept. Eine andere Einlasssituation, die ich tatsächlich als sehr positiv wahrgenommen habe. Ich habe so gut wie nie Schlangen gesehen, sonst gab es immer, das ist so ein, ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr in Braunschweig im Gästeblock schon mal wartet, das ist so ein ganz, ganz abgetrennter Bereich mit so Drehkreuzen und alles ist vergittert. Also es ist wirklich nicht schön.
Drehkreuze sind sowieso raus aus Fußballstadien. Das möchte ich an der Stelle noch mal ganz klar sagen, vor allem das in Braunschweig, weil das nicht funktioniert, dass du quasi dein Ticket vorhältst und dann durchgehst, sondern dass es ein sich quasi von Fans selber gedrehtes Drehkreuz, was einfach dazu führen soll, bevor du dein Ticket kontrolliert wirst, dass die Leute nicht einfach durchgehen. Und die Dinger drehen sich so schnell und ich finde es brutal gefährlich, das nur als kleiner Einwand, weil wir selber im Braunschweig gerade vor einem Monat oder so gespielt haben. Ich finde es eine kaputte Kastrophe.
Einfach nicht gut, ja absolut. Bin ich vorhin ganz bei dir. Es gab jetzt neben diesem Einlasskonzert, die meisten Fans sind mit einem Sonderzug rübergefahren, der tatsächlich so lang war. Ich habe noch nie so einen langen Regionalexpress in Hannover gesehen. Da haben sie einfach zwei hintereinander gehängt und haben quasi alle oder fast alle Fans, die mit Öffis anreisen wollten, dahin gebracht. Dann ist es im Braunschweig so, dass du immer durch den alten Posttunnel hinten rausgehst. Da sammelt man sich dann und dann kommt ein Bus nach dem nächsten. Ich hätte gesagt, das waren so vielleicht 25, 30 Busse. Man mag mich gerne kontrollieren. Die dann relativ zügig die Fans zum Stadion gebracht haben. Auch das ist im Braunschweig nicht so. Man fährt vom Bahnhof zum Stadion, sondern man fährt gefühlt fast wieder zurück nach Hannover, damit man halt nicht da langfährt, wo die Heimfans anreisen. Alles okay. Am Ende kommt alle in den Gästebereich. Der Gästebereich war auch relativ früh sehr gut gefüllt. Da kann man nichts gegen sagen. Im Bereich selber war, glaube ich, die größte Veränderung im Vergleich zum vorherigen Spiel, dass nicht ein Netz, sondern zwei Netze hingen. Also wenn man ein Netz ranzieht und ein Loch reinbrennt oder schneidet, dann reicht das noch nicht. Das Netz davor war so drei, vier Meter weiter vorne. Man kam nicht wirklich ran. Am Anfang gab es noch so ein bisschen Turmulte zwischen Ordnern und so, aber es regelte sich dann und bis zum Ende passierte auch nichts. Es flog nichts aus dem Block. Es brannte nichts auf dem Rasen. Vielleicht brannte es ganz kurz mal. Ihr habt ja gesehen, Pyrotechnik gab es natürlich reichlich und es wird, wenn Frau Behrens schlechte Laune hat, auch dafür reichen, dass sie Gründe findet, von Randale und Ausschreitungen zu sprechen für jemanden, der da sicherlich eine andere Grenze legt, bei was Probleme angeht. Ich habe es vorhin gesagt, was meines Erachtens nicht in Ordnung ist. Ich fand, das war, ja, 5 Minuten Spielunterbrechung müssen auch nicht zwingend sein, aber das ist halt, sollen sie besser einen Rauchabzug einbauen, dann passiert das auch nicht. Also grundsätzlich war das, finde ich, das, was ich bei einem Derby erwarte und so, wie ich mir das vorstelle und das war von daher völlig in Ordnung. Braunschweig selber hatte gar nichts gemacht. Ich glaube, da gab es technische Probleme. Das sollte ja ein Problem sein. Also Hannover wirklich mit einem schönen, soliden Auftritt, ein bisschen Pyro, schön ein bisschen Fahnen, gute Stimmung gewonnen, alles war herrlich. Und ich würde jetzt sagen, ohne dass ich weder bei der Polizei noch beim Innenministerium bin, für mich hat das Konzept funktioniert. Es sind alle heile nach Hause gekommen, hoffe ich zumindest, habe nichts Gegenteiliges gehört. Und es hat, also ich will es vielleicht nicht zu hoch hängen, aber insgesamt hat es das Ganze irgendwie noch mal so ein bisschen, also dieser Tag auf ein vernünftiges Niveau gebracht. Also ja, da werden Sachen gerufen, da können wir lange darüber diskutieren. Muss man nicht, man muss den Gegner nicht als das bezeichnen, was da bezeichnet wurde. Man muss nicht den Tod wünschen und so weiter. Kann aber jeder machen, wie er möchte. Möchte ich mich jetzt hier nicht aufspielen. Ich fand es trotzdem gut, der Stadionssprecher von Braunschweig war gestorben. Hannover hat, als das thematisiert wurde und da nochmal eine Ansprache gab, hat Hannover sich vernünftig benommen. Als Hannover Gästeblog ein Arzteinsatz war und Ruhe war, hatte Braunschweig sich dem angeschlossen. Also, ich sage mal so, die guten Sitten des Fußballs wurden eingehalten und es hat auf beiden Seiten trotzdem, fand ich, vernünftige Stimmung, also von Hannover natürlich logischerweise, bessere Stimmung gegeben, sodass ich sagen kann, das, oder aus meinem Empfinden, war das eine rundum gelungene Sache, die, ja, so kann es gerne bleiben. Also, wir müssen nicht dann irgendwann wieder Bänke ausschrauben und Sitze anzünden und so. Das können wir uns gerne sparen. Lass uns beleidigen, alles gut. Aber vielleicht ohne diese ganz große Schraube.
Ja, als letzten Punkt vielleicht noch, gerade im Bezug auf das Rückspiel. Die Fan-Hilfe Hannover hat da, glaube ich, auch nochmal Punkte aufgelistet und es geht vor allem auch eben, glaube ich, um das Thema Mitbestimmung bzw. mit einem Tisch sitzen, wenn es eben um dieses Thema Sicherheit in den Stadien geht. Es gab ja in der Vergangenheit eben mit den mehreren niedersächsischen Clubs, also Hannover, Braunschweig, Wolfsburg und Osnabrück, eigentlich diese Treffen und da hat Osnabrück unter anderem einmal abgesagt, weil eben die angekündigten Teilnehmer aus der Fanszene eben nicht mit am Tisch sitzen sollten. Und also das ist sowieso ein bekanntes Problem, dass die Problematik sehen wir jetzt auch wieder bei dieser Innenministerkonferenz, dass eben ja Fan-Vertreterinnen da immer wieder ausgeschlossen werden. Und ich glaube, wir können uns generell darauf einigen, dass es mehr Sinn ergibt, mit Fan-Vertretern zu sprechen als über sie, weil dann ist es– also man hat ja zum Beispiel jetzt gesehen, wenn zum Beispiel Clubs mit zusammenarbeiten und klar sagen so, hey, wir sind ja auch fein mit einem Sicherheitskonzept, was ein bisschen nerviger oder ein bisschen strenger geht. Und vielleicht ist es in manchen Sachen sogar sinnvoller, weil es auch einfach um Unsicherheit, in einer Einlasssituation geht etc. Aber nehmt uns doch mit an den Tisch und dann ist es einfacher. Aber also ich glaube, dafür muss man einfach sagen und ohne Daniela Behrens da zu nahe treten zu wollen. Aber ich habe manchmal auch das Gefühl, da besteht überhaupt kein Interesse, da wirklich ein Dialog führen zu wollen, sondern Tobi, ich glaube, du hast es eben immer so nett gesagt, so ihr Profil zu schärfen.
Ja, also man hat ja tatsächlich auch von ihr nichts mehr gehört, als es darum ging, es ist ein voller Stadion oder volle Auslastung. Das hat dann die Polizei Braunschweig kommuniziert. Also natürlich gibt es da auch Verbindung, gar keine Frage, logisch. Aber da war es dann relativ ruhig um sie. Also es ist relativ deutlich, in welche Richtung sie da möchte. Und natürlich hast du auch vollkommen recht, es wird ein Verein, wenn da Martin Kind oder wer auch immer in diesem Treffen sitzt, der wird nicht wissen, wie sich das Drehkreuz im Gästeblock anfühlt. Also der weiß, wie unangenehm es ist, wenn man mit einem H- oder irgendwas Kennzeichen nach Braunschweig fährt. Dass da keiner vielleicht was zu sagen, oder dass das die Häppchen im VIP-Block nicht so gut schmängelt. Ich glaube, der fährt da gar nicht mehr hin. Aber natürlich müssen da auch Leute sitzen, die das Ganze vor Ort kennen und ja miterlebt haben.
Gut, ich würde an der Punkt sagen, wir sind ein bisschen über meine Zeit, die ich haben wollte. Wir hatten aber auch ein, zwei technische Probleme, die ihr hoffentlich nicht so mitbekommen habt. Von daher vielen Dank an der Stelle erst mal für eure Geduld. Ich habe aber noch ein bisschen Hauskeepers zu tun, bevor ich euch verabschiede. Als erstes der Hinweis. Die nächste Sendung, die kommt dann mit Marc am 9. November. Und dann ist wieder Länderspielpause. Ihr habt es hier vielleicht jetzt schon mitbekommen. Wir hatten einmal die Ausnahme, dass wir eben trotzdem eine Länderspielpause aufgenommen haben. Wir wollen jetzt aber wirklich immer schauen, dass wir eben die zwei Spieltage vorbei haben, weil ein Spiel zu besprechen, das ergibt einfach nicht so wahnsinnig viel Sinn. Deshalb kommt dann die nächste Folge voraussichtlich erst am 1.12. Und das liegt daran, dass mein eigener Verein dann an dem Sonntagderby gegen Münster spielt und zur Verschonung aller möchte niemand, dass ich an dem gleichen Abend noch einen Podcast aufnehme. So viel sei schon mal gesagt. Sonst wisst ihr es alle, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch eure Gelder, das ihr eben spendet. Das könnt ihr auf diverse Wege tun. Mehr Infos gibt es da auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub, wenn ihr eben supporter werden wollt. Die Infos findet ihr in den Shownotes. Und der Dank geht stellvertretend heute an Dennis J., Susanne, Nico Rublik, Philipp und Schumi. Vielen Dank, dass ihr bereits den Rasenfunk unterstützt und nicht nur ermöglicht, dass Marc und ich hier sitzen, sondern eben unsere Gästinnen auch entlohnt werden. Zu den Sendungen, die es in dieser Woche gibt oder gegeben hat. Heute ist bereits die Sendung zur Bundesliga der Männer erschienen. Dann gibt es eine Sendung zum Länderspiel der Frauen. Morgen Abend gibt es ja das Rückspiel gegen Frankreich in der Nations League nach dem 1-0-Sieg am Freitag. Darauf könnt ihr euch auch freuen. Es erfolgt eventuell noch ein Teamschwerpunkt im Laufe der Woche. Mal schauen, wer sich da anbietet. Sonst würde ich jetzt tatsächlich sagen, vielen, vielen lieben Dank an meine beiden Gäste. Zum einen Tobi Rieger, danke, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk dabei warst.
Sehr gerne. Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Und vielen Dank auch an Lisa Höfer, dass du dich in ganzem Stress auch Zeit für uns genommen hast. Danke.
Immer sehr, sehr gerne. Und vielen, vielen Dank dir, Eva, dass du dich hier trotz Erkältung durch die Folge gekämpft hast und so gut durchgehalten hast. Also Props und bis ganz bald hoffentlich.
Dann sage ich nur Danke an euch und Tschüss.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.
Lernst ab, ist die Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.